He literally gets a donation that says, "I understand what we
must do." Wink >> Anything is justifiable against Destiny
and the people who support him. No. Is that not the standard?
That's that's what he's laying out for me here. >> Right.
Heman is criticizing Destiny because of Destiny. But for Destiny
quote tweeting that, you don't get the Queenman clip. You don't
get the dicker tweet. You don't get my retweet of the dicker
tweet. But Destiny doesn't care about any of these people. any
any concern he shows is entirely performative and weaponized
against somebody else. He does not feel concern for other human
beings. Well, he's just going to throw up the Odashara clip,
I guess. Guys, we're we're totally we're totally believing the
unhinged like schizophrenic who has no evidence for any of this.
Just made this up while people were calling him a fat in my server,
right? And my bride is coming up to me and asking me if we're
about to be double homicided at her wedding. I'm like, "No, baby.
These people don't leave their mom's basement.
>> 5 minutes to 10 minutes, 10 and 1/2 minutes, 11 and
1/2 minutes on Queen and Me and Auggie. Damn. Damn. >> Bad
Panata is a known doxer and harasser. If you go on his Twitter
account at any time, you could see him doxing people. He's probably
the most famous for being the one who claimed he called CPS on
Ethan and Hila. He's constantly encouraged and defended people
doing it. He literally opened up a CPS merch line because he
thinks it's so funny. >> Got a hat. I did CPS. the CPS
logo with the two skulls. Of course, two skulls not a reference
to anything in >> He knowingly defames people in my last
>> I'll just point out that that is literally you are giving
him exactly what you want there or sorry exactly what he wants.
You're giving bad empanada exactly what he wants. Bad empanada
is literally mocking you for soying the out about him going I
did that right even though he didn't do that. He is just laughing
at you. He is just making fun of you. He's just making fun of
you. He's making jokes about you and you are giving him exactly
what what he wants when you go and replplatform
>> video I pointed out at bad
empanada is a known doxer and harasser. If you go on his Twitter
account at any time, you could see him doxing people. He's probably
the most famous for being the one who claimed he called CPS on
Ethan and Hila. He's constantly encouraged and defended people
doing it. He literally opened up a CPS merch line because he
thinks it's so funny. >> Got a hat. I did CPS. The CPS
logo with the two skulls. Of course, two skulls, not a reference
to anything in >> He knowingly defames people. In my last
video, I pointed out that bad empanada constantly claims that
Lonerbox's dad was part of a militia group that killed a bunch
of civilians. No evidence for it. His response is to give the
most forced laugh I've ever heard.
>> And then he just doubles down on everything he made
up. >> He complains that I called Loner Box, that I said
um that Loner Box's dad uh participated in the Shatilla massacre,
which he absolutely did. By the way, Loner Box has never disproven
this until he disproves that it's true. >> So, I guess
I shouldn't be surprised that when my dog
immediately post >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Hold on. What was the problem there? Was it that he lies
>> and then he just doubles down on everything he made
up? >> He complains that I called Lon. >> Oh, he
just lies and makes things up. Oh, it's almost like is Willie
also saying that it's bad to lie and make things up.
>> That I said uh that loner box's dad. >> Huh? uh
participate in the Sa Chaita massacre, which he absolutely did.
By the way, learn Box has never disproven this until he disproves
that it's true. >> So, I guess I shouldn't be surprised
that when >> were the were the Philangists an elite militia?
Like, was your dad a part of this elite militia? That the fangists
are the elite militia, I guess. >> By the way, Lon Box
is never disproven this until he just proves that it's >> So,
I guess I shouldn't be surprised that when my doc gets found,
bada immediately posted everywhere, uploads a video blasting
my name, my bride's name, the address of our wedding all over
the internet. It's also come out that he's swatting people, filing
fake police reports, all while plugging his Patreon. So, I figured
if he's making money off of my docs, I should, too. I would love
if Willie could get some movement behind doxing off platform
being punishable on YouTube. Oh, man. I I think we could all
come together and go, you know what, Willie Mack, we forgive
you. Okay. If he could get that to get punished on YouTube, if
he could get bad empanada punished for his off-platform behavior
on YouTube, I think we'd all just go, "You know what, Willie,
I I would say it first. I'd be Willie, I forgive you for everything.
Willie, you are the best. Willie, you might actually be the most
intelligent guy here, okay? Cuz I've got, trust me, I've got
some issues with people, okay, who do some some behavior off
platform that they seem to think is totally defended by YouTube."
Sorry. defended under the YouTube ts as long as they do it off
platform. >> Thank you, extter, for helping me cope. Do
you have a big fat bulky wallet that's worn and beat down like
this? Is your friend or family member living with the same?
>> We're not going to watch Willy's ad. We would do it
any other time. Okay. Any other video we'd watch it? We're not
going to watch Willy's ad. stories about me and my wife. >> A
certain slop tuber who does nothing but make videos in which
he attacks pro Palestinian people and de facto as a result of
that helps to further Israel's genocide in Gaza has been outed
as having been honeypotted by Israel. Israel is literally assigning
slop tubers government assigned Israeli wives. Man, Msad's really
good at their job cuz me and my girl started dating 8 years ago
when I was still a nobody on >> Though the slop tuber in
question is Willie Mack show is suddenly making pro Israel content
constantly is suddenly making nothing but videos attacking
>> I uh I'll be honest, I think I threw I didn't throw
a joke out about Willie Mack. I think I asked if uh I think I
asked if Nick had any contact with Israelis recently or something.
>> But it's a joke. It's a joke. It's a >> Covered
Assad before all this. It just turns out a war starting in the
Middle East didn't make him any better at covering the news.
So guess what? I was able to make more YouTube videos. He never
addresses my actual points. It's just character assassinations
for why I should be doxed. Madam Panata then doxes another YouTuber
with the justification that he's a and that it's for journalistic
interest. And then he says that's why it's important to dox me
and my wife cuz she's Israeli.
>> Totally disavow this. By the way, we don't do this.
We don't like doing this. It's actually total garbage. You're
actually allowed to reveal personal information about people,
especially their real names, if it's within journalistic interest.
You know, if there is journalistic
Oh, by the way, just in case Willie does watch this for some
reason. I doubt he will, but just in case he does watch it. When
it first happened to you, I deleted comments. I banned people
and I said, "Obviously, that's a horrific thing to have your
wedding like venue docks." Like, that's that's such dog. It's
supposed to be the the best day of your life. It's supposed to
be the happiest day of your life. And to have that taken away
is really up and I totally disavow anybody doing that. Like it's
it's beyond disgusting. It's beyond just like oh Willy's like
face and name or something. It's like uh it's like actually putting
a target on your back. I I hate that. So
just in case Willie cares, I don't think he believes that at
all when as you go through this >> reason for doing so
and exposing a clear conflict of interest in this guy's content
and his personal life is journalistic interest. It's why for
example I can tell you that the YouTuber Zuma historian a history
YouTuber is this guy. I can tell you this because it is within
journalistic interest to do so even though he did not release
his information himself publicly just like how I can tell you
that Willie Mack show is William McConville and um he is getting
married to Yale. Now I am not going to give you the full name
of um the person he's getting married to. >> He literally
just scrolled down and showed her full name. I reported the video
and he added this little blur, but it still doesn't cover her
name. >> She is Israeli and
wow. It's almost like
information that somebody doesn't want put like maliciously on
YouTube. So, maliciously recorded, maliciously leaked information.
It's almost like you wish YouTubers would like censor that out
of their videos, right? Wow. Uh it's really that it was his wife
because she doesn't deserve that. But my god, Willie, did Willie
just Yeah, Willie saying that it's out there. I don't care anymore.
Um
I don't Dude, what's that a reference to? Putting the cherry
recorded audio in his video, right? Like like obviously he did
that. He's disgusting freak. So >> she was assigned to
him by the Israeli government. They've taken down this page,
but as you can see it is freely available on Google. >> I
do feel really bad for her. I I've progressively lost the empathy
I had for >> they for some reason as the guy who is a public
figure decided to just publicly announce in public his wedding.
>> How is this allowed on YouTube? He does this thing where
he constantly tries to justify his reason for doxing me. He's
like Ethan docs Denims when he sued >> This guy has no
right to complain about
revealing his real name to be doxing because Willie Mac Show
went on the H3 podcast which is a podcast that frequently doxes
people. In Ethan's recent video talking about his uh lawsuit
against free young women, he included unredacted legal legal
filings that he made that include their real names and their
real locations. >> That's just how legal filings work.
>> Here's what
Yeah, that's not how YouTube videos work. How much you want to
bet Willy's got some video on his channel somewhere where he
redacts a legal document for his YouTube video? Yeah. Nobody's
going to dis Nobody's going to dispute that that's how legal
filings work. You've got you've got Photoshop. You've got editing
tools. You can easily add a little black bar to protect that
person's name. Obviously, >> a video clip of Ethan Klein
doxing a random Instagram commenter on his show. >> If
uh if Ethan uploaded the documents to a secondary site as well,
he could redact the names if he wanted to do that. He doesn't
want to do that, right? Obviously, Ethan goes through the guy's
Instagram, brings up pictures of his family members. The >> commenter
commented from their Instagram account with their full name talking
trash to Ethan and had loads of pictures of them and their family
on it. I didn't get sued. I didn't comment on your video with
my full name. At the end of the day, my crimes are marrying a
and going on a podcast. He's non >> Well, that's not even
I don't even think that's actually what he was. That's not even
what Bad Empanada just said. Like, okay, obviously we disavow
it. But Bad Emp was not bad empanata's reason. He just played
bad empanadas reason and then said something totally different.
The the
justification he gave was you do pro-Israel propaganda. That's
a justification. You shouldn't be doxed. Your wife shouldn't
be doxed. wedding venue especially shouldn't be docked cuz that's
literally a time and location. That's super right. But he gave
you the justification. I I think Willy's like,
man, I go back and forth between like Willy's too stupid to understand
like what he does. Like he's too stupid to understand things
or if he's like malicious. I feel like after this video, you
just have to land on stupid, right? Like he is just too dumb.
He actually doesn't understand. He is actually too low IQ to
have his job. And now that so like whoever was writing his videos
for him before like they're gone apparently and now he's on his
own and he is just everything. It's all >> stop lying about
me and my wife saying she was in the IDF. His fans are saying
she murdered babies. He's saying propagandist should die as he's
calling me a paid propagandist. They're saying we're valid.
>> Wow. What what did Willie say when Destiny said me and
Creman should die? What was his response to that? To laugh. To
just laugh. Wasn't that his response? >> He posted a photo
of what he thinks is my wife in the IDF, but they're actually
just pictures of random teenage girls. I asked my wife what this
was, and she thinks it's the Israeli Girl Scouts, so he's just
posting little girls on Twitter. My wife didn't serve in the
IDF. She came over here at 3 years old. On top of it, he doesn't
even know her politics on that situation. He's just being racist.
But the worst thing he did was post the date and address of her
wedding the week before it went. He does it multiple times throughout
the video, showing an archived page of our site because we did
take it down to try and hide it. But nope, there it is. The time,
the date, the address. >> Yale and William McConville are
getting >> Yeah. So, I will say, and by the way, when I
came out and this is the reason I got rid of anybody even referencing
this, right? I didn't I didn't just say like I didn't even say
on stream, don't bring it up. I was like, "Hey, there's information
out there about a certain person. We're not going to bring it
up. You will be banned for this." Right? Because it was specifically
a time and date. A time and date. a time and date that you'll
be in a specific place is explicitly like much more than just
giving out somebody's like address or something or I mean address
is still bad just giving out like their name or pictures or whatever
the right so but I called it out I banned anybody who's even
mentioning not that not that part but who's even mentioning his
information being exposed somewhere I was like no I'll ban you
like you married very soon Yale who is Israeli and Israeli government
provided wife >> so now our wedding is being messed with
and they are wasting the time of our venue, the hotel, and two
police stations. It's costing me thousands of extra dollars in
insurance and potentially closing down the entire building. And
my bride is coming up to me and asking me if we're about to be
double homicided at her wedding. I'm like, "No, baby. These people
don't leave their mom's basement, but she sees the news. She
saw two low-level staffers at the Israeli embassy get shot and
she's worried. So, I'm being told by the police that I should
go online and see if there's any direct threat." I mean, I would
be legitimately
I would be concerned if it was like a date and time, right? Like
that's that's way more specific. Everything else takes way more
work, right? But the date and time thing where it's like, "Oh,
they're going to be here right now." I feel like I would be concerned
>> by a guy who hates me showing all of my information
and giving a >> I know that guy. I know that young >> hypothetical
where I'm a valid target because Destiny's a hypocrite. Stevie
said, "Anything involving this bad empanada guy or anyone that
supports him is justifiable ammo. Anything." So, Queenman is
is criticizing the Destiny quote tweet. Right. By the way, by
the way,
I'll point out Destiny is not saying, "Wow, it's really disgusting
that Willie Mack was doxed." Destiny is not saying, "Hey, Willie,
it's really that you got doxed, buddy." Destiny is not concerned
for Willie Mack. Destiny sees bad empanad as an enemy and he
is attacking that enemy. Right. Willie will later frame this
or has framed it in the past as actually guys
actually
Destiny was just defending me. No, he's not defending you. I
By the way, guys, if you if you see information you believe is
doxing me, please don't try to defend me by amplifying that information
if you don't mind. Okay, that's not defending. That's kind of
weird.
All right. Do we understand? It's kind of weird
>> Sorry, we're cutting We're cutting
>> Stevie said, "Anything involving this bad empanada guy
or anyone that supports him is justifiable." Emmo. Anything is
justified against Bad Empanada and anyone that supports him.
Let's apply those standards. Why are we saying this about Bad
Empanada? Well, it appears to me because Bad and Panada doxed
Willy Mack's wife. So, would Destiny be saying that those who
dox people, those who make calls to violence or illusions to
violence should be fair game? And all of their supporters, all
the personalities that back him up, all the chatters that back
him up. >> This is essentially a Destiny snark community.
this guy's
so Willie will argue he doesn't support Destiny, but he'll totally
he'll totally
every one of Destiny's arguments about me or Queen or whoever,
right? It doesn't matter what the actual reality is. He He doesn't
look anything up. He Destiny says something and Willie goes,
"That's just true. That's Willy's engagement with anything Destiny
has ever said." Anything Destiny has ever said, Willie goes,
"Oh, that's true." Well, that's a fact. No engagement, no asking.
Right? This is why he replatformed the original Kelly Gene thing.
It's why he It's why he just takes anything Destiny says. He's
just like, "Yeah, that's obviously true. That's obviously true."
It's why we had to explain to him, "Hey, when Destiny just lies
about somebody maliciously, like he does this a lot. You should
probably ask why he's doing that." But Willie is once again,
you know, he's spiteful enough that he's forgotten that he conceded
that, right? Hey, Destiny, you you claim this. Do you have any
evidence for this? No evidence. No evidence. Never any evidence.
very sad every time. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. This is of
course another one of these. He he brings this tweet up in the
video. I've seen that before, right? Seen that before. But this
is again I think this is Willy's like complete inability to understand
or comprehend like complex concepts like any sort of abstract
complex concept whatsoever. Like not even complex, but like he's
got like singular understanding of singular nouns or concepts
and like plurals. But like anything where you're you're taking
like a concept and combining it with another, he will immediately
falter. He'll fall apart. His brain will stop working. It overheats.
Steam comes out of his ears. He loses it. Right. So anyway, this
is um Destiny saying that I said having sex with mentally ill
people is obviously not. Uh obviously not. Sorry, I'm laughing
in that like, you know, if I was going to be misogynist here,
I'd say something like uh you know, some scholars argue that
all women are mentally ill. But in in any case, obviously that
would be stupid. And his proof for this is very embarrassing
in this video as well. He just whatever Destiny says, he goes,
"Yeah, um, yeah, that's just true." Destiny said it. Well, that's
what Destiny says is just true, guys. Guys, don't you just copy
everything Destiny says as if it's all facts?
What What could possibly go wrong? Guys, I made a lot of money
by just taking whatever Destiny says and telling everyone else
that that's a fact. Are you telling me that my whole life's been
wrong? that the past three years in my career and and blowing
my channel up in terms of success has just been me repeating
another guy unquestioningly and uncritically. What? Yep, that's
that is the case. >> Narrative for the past 6 months is
that I'm covering for Destiny despite >> Oh, hold on. I
got to back it up. Okay. What I was going to say actually something
else about this Queen thing real quick. Oh. Um, people don't
understand that Queman is like a total narcissist. Queman doesn't
see your on the screen. He's probably not even looking at that
screen. He's probably looking at his chat, possibly a picture
of himself. Actually, that is almost certainly likely. Look at
his eye placement right now. He is almost certainly looking at
himself in his camera and going on a rant about Destiny. He is
not looking at you, Willie. He doesn't even see you on the screen.
He has the clip muted. The clip is playing cuz he just loaded
the page and he's criticizing Destiny. Right. I'm just And by
the way, um obviously bad that he did this. probably if you had
just messaged him about this, he would have immediately taken
it down, which I believe he did anyway. I believe he covered
all of this stuff. He He doesn't want to do that, right? I'm
just telling you for a fact that I know that he's like looking
at himself in the camera or something right now.
This guy obsessively watches all of his own clips, all of his
own segments. Okay? No easier way to get no easier way to get
Queen in a VC than go like, "Hey man, I'm watching like this
clip you were in earlier." Boom. He's in the VC instantly. Boom.
Instant. Okay. So, I'm just I'm telling you that's probably what's
going on here because you don't see him reacting to any of the
information in the video, right? He's just reacting to the Destiny
quote tweet with 227,000
views as of when Queen is viewing this. >> Make calls to
violence or illusions to violence should be fair game and all
of their supporters, all the personalities that back him up,
>> all the chatters that back him up. >> This is
essent Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. That was the other point
here. Sorry. Lot of information, a lot of very misleading things
happening all at once. So Quimman is saying there this is Destiny's
rationale.
Destiny has this rationale for why it's okay to dox people or
threaten them or do whatever, right? If other people are doing
this, you can go after them, right? Uh and you can go after anybody
who supports them like adjacently. Destiny is casting this net
very wide. If people docks, if people um threaten people in some
way, you can go and you can go after them. And so Quimman is
saying, well, obviously under that, you can go after their supporters
too. Anybody who's who supports someone who does that, you can
go after them. So Quinn is saying obviously that would apply
to Willy Mack because we believe you support Destiny, right?
But Queman goes on to say obviously I don't believe that. Obviously
I disavow that. I have principles. I'm principally against doxing.
We don't do that here. We're not [__] around. But
he does say it while smiling. He does say that while laughing.
And so Willie will say, "Oh, no." Like that's proof that he he
he's actually okay with it. No, it's not. And all you'd have
to do to prove otherwise is show any person in Queens community
doxing people. Um, sorry,
hold on. Without retro without um any administrative intervention.
So, if you could show you could show somebody doxing someone
and Queen goes, "Oh, yeah, that's awesome. We're not banning
that guy." Right? But you can't show that. That doesn't exist.
Could there be like individuals who who post someone's picture
or something and get banned? Yes. But you'd have to show like
an explicit lack of intervention, an explicit like allowing of
this to really to really do anything with it. Because as we all
know, as we all know,
you can't control lone wolves on the internet. There are crazy
people on the internet who will do crazy [__] right?
The best you can do as an influencer or some sort of commentator
is to moderate those people out. Those are your rules. I'm so
sick of this of the your disavows are fake argument. It's so
vapid. Well, it's like sometimes there are times where you will
like look at a disavow and you'll laugh. You you'll disavow something,
right? If somebody says something unhinged that I think is funny
that I would personally say, I go, "Oh, no. I totally disavow
that. That's crazy." Right? But I think it's like a whole performance
I put on. It's very easy to tell that apart from it's totally
incredibly easy to tell that apart from what I'm like actually
saying, "No, I don't." And the other proof that you have to back
this up is Queen would have like whole rants where he explains
why he's against doxing, right? Like Queen has a whole set of
beliefs that back up why he's against doxing. I have a whole
set of beliefs that back up why I'm against doxing, right? Why
I never call for it, why I never support it. Yeah. And you just
have like the broad base of their content to look at. You have
like so many things. Just show me where I like advocate for this
for somebody where I do anything like that, right? But they don't
want to. All they want to do is they want to say, "Well, you
know what? Um, you you are vaguely on the team. Um, if I if I
split the world by any line, okay, are you on a team with doxers?
Okay, you can be doxed,
right? So, what's the line that puts me and Queman on the same
team as Kiwi Farmers? Apparently, disliking Destiny.
Apparently, on a on a on a personal level, thinking this guy's
like a total piece of totally reprehensible freak. Apparently,
we share a team on that with Kiwi Farms people. And based on
that, thinking Destiny's like a reprehensible freak, we're open
game or we're fair game to be doxed. That's that's the line.
And we're we're fair game to be put in a category with those
people. I don't want to be put in the category of Kiwi farmer
or doxer because I don't believe in those things. Well, I believe
Kiwi Farms exists obviously, but I don't believe in doxing people,
right? I don't believe that's a good thing to do on the internet.
I don't believe that my ideas are so weak that I have to threaten
somebody's real life person in some way or make them intimidate
their their real life person to make get my point across to make
my point to get my points across. I don't believe in that. Right?
And so I don't want to be put in that category. You can put me
in the category of somebody who thinks Desessie is like a degenerate,
reprehensible, bordering on evil freak of a human being, right?
You can put me in that category. I'm totally comfortable being
there. And if you can put other people in that category who also
happen to be bad, I don't care. You
a Destiny snark community. This guy's narrative for the past
6 months is that I'm covering for Destiny despite me making two
of the most in-depth videos criticizing him. So, the big criticism
of Willie Mack from this video, from the first video he did,
was you missed the whole pattern of behavior. There's a pattern
of behavior that exists with Destiny where he harasses people,
he harasses people who accuse him of bad things, where he weaponizes
his community, where he targets women, right? He he brings them
on his stream, he harasses there's a whole like pattern that
goes on that President Sunday's talked about, that a whole bunch
of people have talked about, right?
That's that's the thing he missed. And I find that awesome. I
find that hilarious because I believe as of the second video
he still doesn't like see it or identify it even though for both
videos he is clearly you know operating on the same sort of like
optics as the Ryan Beard video. And that was what Ryan Beard
points out is you need to watch this pattern of behavior. You
need to see his pattern of behavior over time and identify it
so that you can actually criticize this person correctly. Their
evidence behind this is I said Destiny is better at covering
the news than Hassan and Vos, which is somebody who has made
videos on all three of
that's not what you said, you loser. Do we just have to go get
the clip of what he actually said?
>> Oh, me.
He said he's just lying again. That's not what you said, right?
It's you saying, "Well, as bad as this is for Destiny, uh, like
here's, you know, his competition is like Vosch and this >> I
want to preface. >> Let me let me go find that. Let me
go find the clip cuz hey, let's just go find the clip. Maybe
I'm Maybe I'm misremembering and he doesn't, you know, somehow
put Destiny above those people. Maybe I'm totally misremembering.
I'm actually being serious. It's possible I'm like totally misremembering.
Can I find this in the Oh, am I looking at the wrong video here?
Where is this here? Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. There's a part
with Hassan here. Maybe it's in the other video. Give me a second.
I can't find it in the transcript. Somebody find that clip for
me. In the meantime, what is this? What is this? This clip is
gone. Oh, there's a five at the end. Whoops. What is this? What
is >> Reddit. Cuz like even in the even in the post that
I'm replying to that says Willie stays winning, they're calling
me a abuse enabling piece of human [__] It's like
what have I ever done to deserve that? When have I ever done
that? It's insane. >> Okay. All right. What? I don't have
any commentary here, but apparently cool.
All right. Okay. So, what I believe he said with the Hassan and
Bosch stuff was he basically says like, well, as bad there's
two things, right? the first video he goes as bad as Destiny
is like he does cover the news and his his contemporaries are
like Vos and son and you know he does a way better job than those
guys so you know uh would I ever work with Destiny again I don't
know but he is like really good at the politics thing that's
that's essentially what I believe the the end of the video was
>> I said Destiny is better at covering the news than Hassan
and Vos which is somebody who has made videos on all three of
these people I think that's objectively true but I digress
>> oh and he said oh it was something about his his belief
in destiny Right. It's that's what it is. It's something about
his belief in destiny. I I should go find it. >> It's that
when these two do something stupid, I make fun. >> The
truth is bad empanada did not originate my docs. He maliciously
spread it every
>> Wait, nobody has any problem with somebody making fun
of people
who's who's got a problem with with making fun of people >> but
my docs originated on a niche form by this guy's unhinged viewers.
So when I see this clip, it's obviously a dog whistle. So Willy
M's docs apparently was dropped by a Queenman viewer. So Willy
Mack must have some evidence of this, right? Willy Max Willy
surely isn't out here making allegations like that. Queman's
community doxed me.
surely he's not out here making that allegation again
with zero evidence, right? Surely he's learned something. Every
time he makes an allegation with zero evidence, every time he
reamplifies something deesty says, just literally sucking Destiny
off instead of actually questioning anything Destiny says.
And every time the whole commentary community comes together
and goes, Willie, you're crashing out. Willie, you are losing
it. Willie, you don't understand what Willie just show us any
evidence for something you're saying. He's now tripled down.
He's doing it again. First one was Oh, what was the first one?
The first one was, was it this is just true? the cherry thing,
the the me saying uh he he amplifies Destiny saying that Oh,
that I said mentally ill women is right. There's this one and
there's a second one. Oh, that I doxed him. Yeah, that I was
doxing him. Bro, what are you doing?
Why does he just keep taking what Destiny says as fact with no
checks? By the way, that was a criticism of him in his first
video. Hey, why did you replatform this thing about Lavin Kelly
Jean without like asking anybody, without asking for evidence?
You just posted it and said that was the case, right? You just
posted and said, "Well, Destiny said this. Why didn't you look
into it? Destiny lies about people. You know that, right?" But
then he says Destiny, "Oh, well, we aren't to that yet." No spoilers,
bro. No spoilers. No spoilers. We got to keep watching the It's
Dude, it's like the density of just misrepresentations and lies
is so heavy that it's difficult to wait through this video. It's
just like I'm I'm literally I'm literally waiting through just
pile massive piles of [__] I can't even watch the
video with any kind of flow criticizing him. Their evidence behind
this is I said Destiny is better at covering the news than Hassan
and Vosch, which is somebody who has made videos on all three
of these people. I think that's objectively true, but I digress.
But most importantly, it's that when these two do something stupid,
I make fun of them back. The truth is bad empanada did not originate
my docs. He maliciously spread it everywhere. But my docs originated
on a niche form by this guy's unhinged viewers. So when I see
this clip, it's obviously a dog whistle to with me. He literally
gets a donation that says, "I understand what we must do." Wink
wink. Max. Max. This is why you need to chill sometimes, Max.
Realistically, we all know Max is This is a meme, right? This
is a meme that happens in a whole bunch of communities. You say,
"I disavow that. I actually disavow that. I am principally against
that." Right? and and they go, "I understand. This is I've seen
this in Chud's community a bunch." Right? Stila loves to say
this, right? Chud goes, "Don't do this, guys. This is clearly
up." And and Stila goes, "Yes, Mr. Logic. I understand perfectly.
I will deal with this." Right? It's the It's the It's the Trump
January 6th meme. Oh my god. Sorry. Let's back it up again. >> He
literally gets a donation that says, "I understand what we must
do." Wink wink. anything is justifiable against destiny and the
people who support him. No. Is that not the standard? That's
that's what he's laying out for me here. Now, I have principles.
I have principles. I don't think it's no bad tactics, only bad
targets. That's not me. As he's literally showing, >> so
I'll point out that as Queenman states his principle here, right,
the principal position as he does that, he's not laughing, he's
not smiling, he is saying it seriously. >> I don't think
it's no bad tactics, only bad targets. That's not me. >> As
he's literally showing my docs, >> but Destiny is very
clearly laying out that those are the standards that >> Now,
that's unfortunate. As I've seen, guys, or as I've already said,
guys, the best explanation for this is that Queman is just staring
at a full screen monitor of his own camera, admiring himself.
He is famously narcissistic. He is incapable of looking away
from his own reflection. Okay, he is narcissist
reborn.
All right, that's he's not he's not looking at what's on his
screen at all. that he believes in. >> But what did he
do when he was informed that this existed, right? Got the clipper
to take it down, censored his own videos, right? He got rid of
everything. Oh, I don't even Do I want to click on this Nicholas
tweet? I don't want to click on this Nicholas tweet and interrupt
things. I'll see what it says.
sorry. I'll pull it up. I'll pull it up. Uh, Auggie tweets, the
Cabal is angry with me, and I'm not specifying which one. You
can just say it's Willy. So 3,000 don't think this is about me.
I I would say
I I get Nicholas doesn't want to get heat for this, right? Nicholas
didn't do it. I All Nicholas has to do is watch the stream, right?
Just watch or sorry, watch the video on your stream. It's a big
video. Watch the video on your stream. Give your take on it.
That's all. I don't even I'm not going to I don't I want to be
friends with Nicholas. Okay. I believe Nicholas
Nicholas knows what he's doing. Nicholas retweeted the video.
Means nothing. It's not him. It's him signal boosting his friend.
I don't even know that he's watched the video yet. Okay, if he
But if he doesn't watch that video on stream and give his commentary
honestly,
I feel like that's really disingenuous.
You got to give your honest commentary on this video. That's
all I ask and I won't I won't do anything else to say anything
bad about it. Okay, just give your honest commentary.
How do you think Willie did? Okay, we continue. Those are the
standards he he wishes to be enforced is if you're a doxer, if
you call for violence, anything is justifiable against you supporters.
>> Order taken. >> Okay, that's not what I'm saying,
Max. Actually, I just explicitly said otherwise, actually, Max,
>> he's got a grin on his face. Knows what he's doing.
This thing gets retweeted by his friend Jtock, who pushed the
exact same narratives about me. I'm obvious
he knows what he's doing. this thing gets >> Did I say
I think my thoughts on Willie were always he understands where
his audience is, but he doesn't explicitly support Destiny. He
understands he has to support like all of these narratives, right?
Because that's what his audience wants, but he doesn't he doesn't
directly support Destiny, right? He obviously made the videos
that were critical of Destiny. Um I think there's softening.
So, and now I mean with the further conduct I'm I'm like, "Oh,
now maybe I was just wrong." But the the narrative I always tried
to follow was I think he understands the audience that he's got.
He understands how it's very difficult to totally extricate himself
from Destiny. So while he burns Destiny, he's not going to like
he's not going to back off a lot of the positions around it,
right? And he'll try to be fair. Well, more fair I would say.
But I don't think he like outrightly
man I should say I did not think originally at the time that
he outwardly supported Destiny. I think some of the stuff he's
been doing kind of leans toward more towards like, yeah, you
do kind of you might actually support this guy. So, I don't want
to because I might have said something in the past week, two
weeks, three weeks that leans in that direction. I think it's
changed with his conduct as time's gone on. Anyway, apparently
this was me retweeting Willy's docs, just totally agreeing with
Dickers and retweeting this. I didn't even know that uh I didn't
even like look at any of this. I was just like, "Oh, boom. Retweet."
retweeted by his friend Jtock who pushed the exact same narratives
about me. I'm obviously very unhappy about this, it's affecting
my real life. But instead of anyone actually acknowledging this,
they do what bad empanada did and try to hypocrisy hunt to justify
their
So again, he blames me for this and literally I ban people. I
silence people for like trying to even bring up his docs. I said
that's up. Obviously, I've been super fair about like the doc
happening. Right. Right. I've been super I've been super clear
like, "Hey, that's incredibly I don't I don't support this. It's
really bad." But he doesn't even he doesn't I thought this was
a guy who reached out to everybody involved with the story. Why
didn't he like message me about any of this? He didn't. He never
messaged me about any of this, right? I could have just been
like, "Here's clips of me totally disavowing this. Here's like
logs of me banning people. Here's like you could just know what
my opinion is."
But no, he just assumes it and gets it totally wrong again. >> Actions.
They're like, "Why aren't you mad at Destiny? He quote tweeted
your docs, too." >> Why aren't you mad at Destiny himself?
>> That's a great question. >> Defending my already
viral docs. That's
>> No, he's not. He's just call He's just saying anything
you do to bad empanada is fine. He's not saying how do you even
defend a doc? What does that look like? Wait, hold on. How do
you defend? How How are you defending it? What? Loki Coco, that's
totally fine. I don't expect any of them to watch my stream unless
they want to make claims, right? If you want to make claims,
you should have something to back it up. Like anything,
anything to back it up. He only cares if you're nice about it
or using it to call him a hypocrite. I don't Dude, he like it
doesn't make any sense here. And by the way, I don't know if
he even shows the tweet. He accused me on Twitter of doxing him,
right? He literally said, "This guy's like spreading my docks."
I'm like, "No, I'm not. What the are you even talking about?"
So, again, it's his accusation that makes everybody go, "Wait,
what the?" Because if I was spreading his docs by retweeting
dickers, then obviously Destiny was spreading his docks and there
is no differentiation that can be made, right? There's just no
differentiation. He's been on Destiny's tips since day one. Well,
he's a notoriously low information operator. Low information
operator >> already in the hands of all the people who
hate me. We're acting like context and scale don't matter. >> Context
and scale. Okay, you could say the context is I like Destiny.
And he was quote tweeting to say somebody should kill this bad
empanada guy. So actually that's okay. You could say that, but
don't say anything about scale, okay? Because he's clearly the
biggest the biggest creator retweeting this or quote tweeting
this. It's literally the quote tweet that Queen is referencing
in his clip, right? He Queman is criticizing Destiny because
of Destiny, but for Destiny quote tweeting that, you don't get
the Queen clip. You don't get the Dicker tweet. You don't get
my retweet of the Dicker tweet. Do we understand causality? Do
we understand cause and effect? Apparently not. Apparently, there's
no care for that. It was actually kind of nice to see someone
with a big audience who I've criticized in the past stand up
for me and say this is wrong. But look at >> is there is
there stuff here that I'm missing where Destiny said this is
wrong. He just said someone should kill this bad empanada guy.
I got news for you Willie. That was Destiny's position already.
That's not Destiny going wow this is really too far. Uh this
is really up. No Destiny's position was already someone got to
kill this guy. That was already Destiny's position a long time
ago. He doesn't go oh it's so disgusting that Willie got doxed
here. He goes, "Yeah, somebody nothing done against this bad
empanada guy could possibly be wrong." Hey, his opinion on bad
empanada changed 0% from that happening. He just quote tweeted
you cuz he was like, "Oh, this helps me prove my point. This
guy sucks." And you can tell that because he is obviously spreading
your docs, right? And he doesn't even give you one iota of thought.
He just spreads it, right? He just spreads it
cuz he's a doxer. He doesn't give a [__] about it.
That's your guy. this comment. Willie refuses to acknowledge
the obvious that Destiny is the biggest proponent in spreading
his >> four book post on the clip live subre obviously
indicative of the public zeitgeist on this >> this comment
will refuses to acknowledge the obvious that Destiny is the biggest
proponent in spreading his docks. No, it was actually bad empanada
who did that. Do you know how time works? They hate destiny so
much they're ignoring the very reality we live in. That's >> Wait,
but shouldn't the number of people it goes out to matter? Does
Willie not realize that? like, "Okay, I I understand this. Even
if somebody on your side amplifies it, that's going to cause
other people to come along and disagree with them and amplify
it further, right?
It's it's" And he's not even making a moral point. He's just
saying, "This guy's got to die." He's just saying, "Anything
you do to this guy is fine."
He's literally just going, "Hey, quote tweet, we got to kill
this guy." That's all Destiny's doing. That's what I don't get
at all. Is he perfectly fine with it? The point was about size,
but that can't be the point. Desi's got a way bigger platform
than Bad Empanada. Like, obviously, Dario said in his server,
"Yeah, that's I that's fine." Um, that's Yeah, I totally I believe
that. I don't think he I think Nicholas would not have retweeted
this if he'd watched the video and seen Willie doing this. Willie
is literally doing he he's pulled a page from the Keff's playbook.
Not unlike Destiny, right? They've both pulled a page directly
from the Kefl's playbook and they're running with it. It's like
I Oh, I I Dude, this is just this is just a little bit
>> We might look into this a little bit later. Okay, but
obviously
Lily did Keles's content. One of the biggest criticisms of Keles
was you built this entire stop Kiwi Farms movement knowing that
a bunch of your harassment is not coming from Kiwi Farms. You
did it to support your own ends. You did it because of your own
vendetta against this platform. And that maps cleanly one to
one onto what Destiny is doing with my community and Queenman's
community. He is trying to attach us to Kiwi farms. He is trying
to say these communities are responsible for all of this behavior.
Right? He is making us respon. He's literally saying I'm going
to dox and harass anybody from these communities I can because
they're responsible for this behavior. It just cleanly maps on,
right? And Willie points this out. Willie points out that Keville
is lying. I'm sure there's more where he actually criticizes
this lie, points out why it's bad, and somehow he cannot map
this same concept, this same abstract concept that's a little
difficult to understand when it's applied in a different scenario,
right? Furthering my idea that Willie doesn't understand hypotheticals,
can't comprehend hypotheticals, is too low IQ to comprehend,
you know, hey Willie, how would you feel if you didn't have breakfast
this morning? He can't do it. Is impossible.
>> Okay, give it attention. So, like them, we will refer
to it as website zero. Website zero is what Keles portrays Kiwi
Farms as. Kiwi Farms in reality is just a glorified gossip forum
where people like to troll and use slurs. Website Z Oh, I guess
it's I guess it's 2 years ago, 2022. I guess it's maybe maybe
Kiwi Farms wasn't doxing anybody. Maybe Kiwi Farms didn't have
Keel's docs in Keel's >> On the other hand, is a coordinated
effort by users meant to harass their target, not just on online,
but in real life as well. So, like if you're just talking about
people, that's not really that bad. That's just trolling. But
the actual actions, the taking steps to dox or harass these people
in real life are that that's the bad thing. Yeah, I agree. Quan
agrees. We all agree. Okay, we all agree. Sorry, this is a 2-year-old.
This is from his KEFL's one of his Keful's videos. Jacob.
Okay. Is there even evidence that a queen of Eurodox him? No,
he is just one to one taking the exact
Destiny talking points and spitting them back out, right? He
is just going to take the Destiny talking points and repeat them
verbatim with no checking of any facts. A thing he's already
been criticized for multiple times. And yeah, that's all he's
doing. That's all he's doing. That's all he's capable of. This
is a different video though, Jacob. It's his Keles video. So,
he can identify this misrepresentation as bad when Keles is doing
it. But when Destiny does it, he goes, "Yes, yes, Mr. Destiny,
sir. Yes. Yes, of course I will. Of course I'll amplify that.
Of course I'll agree with that. Of course that's correct. And
why does he do this? I who knows. Okay. Who knows? With his docs
being spread around as long as the person who's spreading it
is condemning it. At this point, my docs is already spread. The
toothpaste is out of the bottle. What bothered me most in this
moment was the narrative that I deserve it or that it's part
of some greater Destiny justice. If Yeah. Cleman doesn't believe
that. Queen is saying that if you if you used Destiny's
if you used Destiny's modest operandi, okay, his his claim, his
beliefs, then you would think Willie deserves it. Destiny community
viewers have to believe that Destiny community members and supporters
deserve to be doxed. That is built into everything Destiny is
telling you. I understand you guys are you probably don't understand
that if you're in that community, right? But that is what Destiny
is claiming now. by Destiny's actions, you all deserve if you
are doxed, you are totally opting into that by being a supporter
of his.
That's the point Queen's making. And the point with all of that,
okay, there's a that's a part of a broader point, which is clearly
Destiny's lost his mind, right? Clearly, that can't be the standard
by which any creator operates. Oh, anybody who supports someone
who does doxing is now involved in the doxing themselves. That's
[__] nuts. That's clearly [__] nuts.
But Willie doesn't understand. >> Hulled up my docs and
only said bad empanada sucks for this. I wouldn't care. It's
the dog whistle call to action that's the problem. It's so obvious.
Yet I'm seeing respected commentator Auggie call me a hypocrite
because I said doxing is wrong. >> This is it's only obvious
if you have to cut out a ton of the clips. Right. That's the
only time it becomes obvious. You have to cut out a whole bunch
of the context in the clips where Queen says, "Yes, this is actually
really bad. Don't do this." >> From a month ago, Willie
says, "You should delete this. It's just doxing and a [__]
to do to someone whose worst crime is being annoying on the internet.
So you have that situation there. So there is Twice replying
to Jay- Sock's docs, but then he got
upset about
his docs being shared. >> Yeah. Holy [__] It's
as if context matters. It's as if me calling out a tweet that
already has 100,000 views doesn't add any negative effect. He
pearl clutches and gives this big performance about my quote
tweet. >> I showed you two times. Here he is doing it a
third time just a few days ago before I even did this stream
and I actually had like tell him I was like dude delete this
right >> but on this >> wait so if Willie if Willie
agreed with this right if disagreed with this stream and I actually
had like tell him I was >> so before we go any further
here I just want to point out that Auggie tweeted hey why are
you doing this and Willie immediately deleted his tweet right
so if he disagrees with anything Auggie is saying if he disagrees
with Auggie that this is a bad thing to do why did he delete
his tweet just off the off the dome. That would be the first
thing I ask. Why did he delete his tweet here if he doesn't believe
that this is bad? >> Like, dude, delete this. Right. >> But
on the same stream, Auggie shows the uncensored link of Jto's
docs. He also replied under Jto's docs on Twitter. So, what are
we talking about? Are we going >> Yeah, Auggie Auggie did
essentially the same thing. Right now,
now
what Auggie didn't do and what I wouldn't do is I wouldn't go
and go, if you if you retweeted a clip from this, I wouldn't
go, "Hey, Willie Mac, why are you trying to dox me? Why are you
doxing me right now, Willie Mack?" Right? If Willy Mack retweeted
a clip that where this information wasn't even on screen, but
eventually this information made it onto screen, I'm go, "Willy,
why are you doxing me?" One, fail docs. But two, uh, yeah, I
just we wouldn't do it. Like, it's stupid. It would be so Willy
can't be mad at the Jtock retweet apparently that yeah none of
the none of what I did was ma bad but he said oh any any doxing
of me is fine totally justified >> call Auggie is Nick
going to have to take out Willie of Mice and Men style I mean
after this video yeah I would assume so I would assume all Auggie
has to do is go live and say Willie call into the showy call
into the show and defend yourself Willie call into the show right
now actually come talk this out because this is embarrassing
for all of us Willie Willie what are you It's all got to all
that's got to be >> A doctor. No, because they don't actually
care about this. He's just being performative to justify what's
happening to me. Auggie acts confused to He's not justifying
what's hap What? Where does Auggie ever go? Oh, it's totally
based that somebody doxed Willie. Oh, it's totally good. It's
good that somebody are Are you saying he's going out of his way
to justify like my retweet?
Then maybe he's justifying the ret justifying the retweet. I
think he's saying it's an understandable mistake more than justifying
it, right? I don't even I don't know how you could possibly argue
that Auggie justifies Willie Max Willy Mack being doxed in this
stream.
That's wild throughout this entire >> Literally days after
he threw a hissy fit. Yeah. I mean, it just doesn't really make
any sense to me. It's like what the are we talking about here?
I mean, what are what argument are we making here? >> I
messaged Auggie and pointed that pointed out that this is uncensored.
I just don't as long as it's not like my information. I just
don't kind of just like I think I said, "Hey man, you should
go to like you should go to like that docs cuz that's a way less
fat picture. You should actually pull that up on stream." I think
I said this is a way less fat guy that they do there. Pull that
one up. Pull that up on your stream right now. >> It's
just crazy. It makes no sense. >> I know why he's confused.
It's because he never plays the original clip that made me mad
in the first place. He just summarizes as they criticize Destiny
and that's why Willy's mad. too bothered by
>> The the basic point here the whole time that Auggie
is going to keep doing and everyone else is going to keep doing
is why could you possibly so Destiny saying, "Oh, anything done
against bad panata is bad." He's not defending you or oh, or
anyone that supports him is justifiable. IMO, right? We're criticizing
this sentiment coming from Destiny because that means anybody
who supports Destiny deserves all of these same things, right?
So obviously
that's the criticism. That is a criticism of doxing in in abstract.
Okay. So when we're all looking at this tweet, we're going, "Hey,
you Destiny, you don't like doxing. How how are you going to
cut Destiny out of that equation?" Right? Everybody Everybody
reacted to this. Every single thing, including the clip, including
the Dickers retweet, including my retweet or the Dickers quote
tweet, including my tweet retweet of Dickers, all of it is downstream
of the Destiny quote tweet. Destiny amplified this to everybody.
How are you not angry at Destiny, but you are angry at us for
calling out somebody who doxes people? Are you just angry that
we did? Do you think that it only applies to Destiny doxing people?
You think it doesn't apply equally to to bad empanada? That's
not how we operate, man. How is that confusing? >> But
instead, he was bothered by some stuff that um and JTO were saying.
And basically what they were saying was it's kind of hypocritical
for Destiny to get upset at, you know, Willie Mack for getting
docs when he has a history of doxing people and is currently
right now calling for their doces. Right. >> So he never
plays the context and then acts like the reason I'm mad is because
they called Destiny a hypocrite. Nothing about my
>> Wait, did Auggie not Hold on. Do we have to go back
and watch this Auggie thing? Cuz I feel like Auggie What? I feel
like Auggie There's no way. Why would you show the original clip
if it has his docs in it? Uh, that would be one thing to ask.
Yeah, that he if he didn't have it censored, right? But apparently
Willie Mack is also saying something along the lines of like
what is he also saying? He's like also saying here at different
points that like my doc is already viral so like it doesn't matter
if it's spread. Like he has to have a cope so that I don't know
why you have this cope that like oh well the doc is out there
so now doxing is not bad.
People amplifying my docs is not bad. Well, as long as it's Destiny
and he's amplifying it to defend me. I Okay,
I'm I'm going to go back. You know what? I might be chopping
this up too much. Let me go back and just
There's so many statements. It's so dense. Okay, it is denser
than Willy's skull. It's so difficult to make it through this.
I'm going to go back and see if maybe maybe I'm just not understanding
his art. >> But on the same stream, Auggie shows the uncensored
link of JSTalks docs. He also replied under JSTalks docs on Twitter.
So, what are we talking about? Are we going to call Oh, also
replied under Jtox docs on Twitter to criticize, right? The whole
point, the hypocrisy Augie is calling out here is you're mad
that somebody is criticizing doxing under your docs, right? But
you have also done this repeatedly. So, you are a hypocrite.
You don't really believe this. You've gone and replied to JCO's
docs multiple times. That's the point Auggie is making. You don't
believe this is a bad thing by your own actions. You do not believe
this. That's the argument. Okay, let's let's once again just
crystallize that in our heads. This is we won't pay attention
to the fact that this is Auggie replying to Willie Mack doing
this exact behavior. >> Call Auggie a docer. No, because
they don't actually care about this. He's just being performative
to justify what's happening to me. >> He's saying that
it's really cringe. It's really embarrassing for you to have
a whole spur out where you reply to multiple people on Twitter.
There are massive tweet threads about this. You reply to multiple
people in your subreddit. There's massive threads about that
where you eventually delete all your posts because you look like
a Right. He's criticizing you for having a total spur out about
this and then doing it the next like like 3 days later, 4 days
later, 5 days later maybe.
Yes, you look like a total idiot. Auggie X confused throughout
this entire segment. >> Literally days after he threw a
hissy fit. Yeah. I mean, it just doesn't really make any sense
to me. It's like what the are we talking about here? I mean,
what are what argument are we making here? This is just crazy.
It makes no sense. >> I know why he's confused. It's because
he never plays the original clip that made me mad in the first
place. He just summarizes as they criticize Destiny and that's
why Willy's mad >> too bothered by this, but instead he
was bothered by some stuff that um Queman and Jtock were saying.
And basically what they were saying was it's kind of hypocritical
for Destiny to get upset at you know Willie Mack for getting
docks when he has a history of doxing people and is currently
right now calling for their doces. Right. So he never plays the
context and then acts like the reason I'm mad is because they
>> the context that includes Willy's docs by the way. >> Old
Destiny a hypocrite. Nothing about my wedding or my bride. How
is that possible? Unless you're being bad faith. I'm not even
sure if Auggie knows what a dog whistle is. He's like unless
pulls up Willy's docs and then says I love doxing Willie. It's
all fine. This seemed really a point. >> Queen doesn't
like doxing. Queman has consistently laid out the exact same
>> against Willie Mac. It was mainly a point against Destiny.
I don't think at any point Queen was like, "Yeah, and he got
docks and I love that." You know, I don't think he ever said
that. Right, >> bro? If you're this stupid, make life better
for everybody and just quit. Destiny is recently. >> Wait,
were you a part of the original clip? No, I wasn't. I So, Queen,
it's a Queenman clip, right, where he's talking about like what
this means. Okay, we've got the Destiny tweet, the quote tweet,
which says any action against bada or anybody who supports him
is totally justified. And Quimman points out that obviously that
Destiny is signing up his own viewers and supporters in terms
of content creation to be doxed or whatever the right any action
against them is bad. Literally, I guess you could say he's calling
for violence against anybody who would support somebody who dox
his people, right? So, he is actually calling for violence against
his own fans assuming that you have any assuming that he's not
just totally spiked driven that he hates banana specifically,
right?
He's saying anything done against this guy. Right. So, Queen
is saying, well, if you if you want to say that this is the impetus
for making the tweet is Willie being doxed and that this is what
has changed his position or formed his position, then here's
the argument Destiny is making, which is clearly unhinged and
stupid. >> Dox Jstalk and Queman. His motivation behind
this is that everyone they associate with him ends up getting
doxed and harassed. So, he's doing it back to them. The victims
I know are Destiny's girlfriend, Dan. >> Destiny's girlfriend.
Originally doxed before Quean and I were out against him, I believe,
as far as I know. Uh, I'm like 80% sure or 90% sure on that one.
Destiny, by the way, pulled up her docs on his stream. Her full
name docs on his stream. Okay. >> Consultment and his family.
>> Uh, Dan, I don't know what happened with Dan. I can't
remember the dates on the Dan stuff for sure. Uh, I I actually
don't know, so I'm not going to make any claims on the Dan stuff.
Obviously, we disavow all >> and my wife. Hutch and >> so
Willie Mack and his wife. That was after as well. >> His
family >> Hutch and his family. Hutch and his family come
before as well. Originally doxed in April. Okay. Originally doxed
in April. And I'll remind you that Destiny himself has asked
for and retweet or sorry and and posted the docs for Jacob. Okay.
Somebody in our chat in our community just because those people
were shiting him, right? So would Destiny say he's doxed them?
I thought Destiny said reposting docs or or uh push pointing
people towards docs on Kiwi Farms is not in fact doxing. I thought
that was his whole point. That's how he denies doxing, right?
That's how he denies doxing. So all of these people, a bunch
of these people actually had this stuff all happening to them
before Queen and I were ever like identifying targets or something.
This concept that Quimman and I are identifying targets. I don't
know if Hutch even knows that. Did Destiny notify Hutch when
Hutch was doxed in his Kiwi Farms thread? Destiny watches this
thread. Did he notify Hutch? I know he didn't notify him the
second time. Actually, I know he didn't notify him at all because
if he had, he would have said to that DJer who asked him if he's
going to notify Hutch this time. No, I've already told him about
it. But Desi doesn't care about any of these people. Any any
concern he shows is entirely performative and weaponized against
somebody else. He does not feel concern for other human beings.
Auggie pulls up Destiny's employee saying she was >> I
was also swatted.
Now, why would she be saying that she was also swatted in a reply
to this clip? Oh, that's a great question.
When when did that happen to Arrodite? Now, here's the thing.
I think it's possible that this happened to Arrodite. Let's say
it's possible that this happened to Arrodite after maybe she
moved after January 20th. Maybe she moved and she went to a new
address and that new address was doxed and swatted. But if that's
not the case, there's no reason to attribute that to Queen or
me, right? At all. Give me a second. Give me a second. I'm pulling
this out. bridges this guy
>> So, let's see here.
Let me pull the transcript for this. This is from January 2nd,
2025 before Queen and I were talking about any of this stuff
uh super openly at least >> about like the level of
hate that like I get as like a nobody. >> They're always
like that's like unhinged. Like I I actually had to call the
police recently. Um, they said that I had already had three calls
about my home address, which is crazy, right? And they're like,
"Don't worry, they were not very believable, blah blah blah blah
blah." But it's very, um, it feels like I don't know if it's
a politics specific thing, but when I talk to content creators
who do like science creation, >> so sorry, that's multiple
times by January 2nd, she tells me, I believe on January 23rd,
I'd have to look up the date for sure, that she was swatted as
well, right? I believe it's January 23rd. I'd have to go find
it here really quickly. Let me see if I can find it. Uh, this
is actually probably important to go find, but I believe that
this is just leaning into
uh
God. I I can find it at some other point. She tells me in logs
directly that she was do she was swatted like before this had
really kicked off or any of this stuff is was being talked about.
So, it's possible she she moved and was redoxed and re-watted.
But I would ask, if you're going to imply that Queen has something
to do with you getting swatted, shouldn't it be something that
took place after January 20th? Shouldn't it be something that
took place after the quote unquote unhinged coverage started?
Why would you assert that we're pointing people towards you?
We're we're labeling you guys as targets when we're not even
against you. I was defending you on January 20th. I literally
went out of my way to tweet to defend Ardite and what she had
done on January 20th, January 23rd, somewhere in that first week.
Right? So, I wonder why she's then leaning into the idea that
Queman and I helped docer swat her,
right? I would be very curious about this. >> Is she saying
that Jay- Sock and Queen had some part in her getting swatted
or that their communities had some part in >> Yes, obviously.
But it's all just a coincidence to Auggie. Augie pulls up another
example of a Destiny viewer saying they're getting threatening
letters sent to their house and Destiny is like, I don't believe
them. But even if that happened, it's still not that community's
fault. A couple months ago, cuz I'm a fan of Destiny in the JSON
server, someone in his community sent a letter to my home. I've
moved since then. Thanks for telling us, by the way, to my house
saying, "I defend I want to my wife and my patients."
Well, he's just going to throw up the Odashara clip, I guess.
Cool. Guys, we're we're totally we're totally believing the unhinged
like schizophrenic who has no evidence for any of this. Just
made this up while people were calling him a fat my server, right?
So, he just made it up cuz I believe he was out there, you know,
trying to push out the what was it the implied consent arguments
or something and it happened to be like, well, you guys shouldn't
say that like I defend, you know, you guys shouldn't say that
like I defend email or something because then people will harass
me in real life. That's that was his position. And it's like,
"Okay, so he said that and then within I believe within days
or weeks." Then he's like, "I got a letter in real life." Yeah.
Okay. Can I see the letter? No, I threw it out immediately. The
thing that I said was going to happen happened and I have no
proof of it, but I I It happened.
Okay. Um,
that seems really weird. Apparently, somebody has your address
and is trying to threaten you. You're just going to take no action
on that? You're just going to do nothing about that? Okay. Uh,
he believe he said later that he was 98% sure it was not somebody
from my >> I'm going to put an X to dial on that one. And
even if it did happen, right, who's responsible for that? >> What
about the guy dog whistling that I'm a valid target and getting
a dono saying they understand his orders? >> Wait, does
Willie Mack not understand cause and effect? One, he's not saying
you're a valid target. He's saying Destiny is making you a valid
target. And two, you're already dodge.
How did he How did he make you a target before you were ever
How did he make you a target after you were targeted? How how
how
dude what are we doing? Apparently Quimman made him a target
before saying this, right? And now this saying this pointing
to Destiny's justifications, Destiny's arguments and saying that's
insane. Apparently that is proof that Quimman believes in Destiny's
arguments.
Cool. Cool. Cool. anything is justifiable against Destiny and
the people who support him. >> I don't think creators are
responsible for every >> It's like that is that right there
that is the most malicious clipping I've ever seen and anybody
in the commentary community who doesn't call Willie a lying for
this is compromised. They they should be totally cast out. You
are lying. You He is just openly lying here. He is just taking
something that is explicitly being used for the opposite purpose
and lying about Quimman right now. By the way, I'll also point
out that when this clip was there, did did Willie go to Twitter
and say, "Quiman's amplifying my dogs." Did he do that? You go,
"Hey, Queen Quimman's posting my dog. Quinnman's putting my dogs
out there." No, he came after me for some reason. Why? He came
after me for a retweet. I don't even understand. Like, to me,
I that's something I don't comprehend. I literally don't get
why he didn't come after Queman in the first place. I think I
said that at some point like technically he's got like a way
better claim against Queen here. So maybe maybe he'll do that.
I don't I don't know. >> It's justifiable against Destiny
and the people who support him. >> I don't think creators
are responsible for every one of their unhinged viewers, but
it is not normal for a community this small to have so much doxing
coming out of it. I've made videos on commun
>> uh just any proof of the doxing coming out of it. Literally
any proof? Are you just making another claim based on apparently
there's a there's a direct correlation between how often you've
copied Destiny in the past with uncritically and like your likelihood
to do it in the in the future. I was going to I was going to
do a come drinking joke there actually, but I'm trying to wean
off of those. We don't we don't want to do those anymore. We
don't want to be like other uh disgusting freaks. Okay. Like
he's just been licking Destiny's balls for this long that he
will actually just replplatform anything Destiny says uncritically.
It's
nuts. Destiny And now he's going to make a Keles point. I don't
understand what point he could possibly make about Keffles right
now. I actually don't know >> and the people who support
him. >> I don't think creators are responsible for every
one of their unhinged viewers, but it is not normal for a community
this small to have so much doxing coming out of it. I've >> So
again, um that's because people are lying. Most of the doc's
Willie references were actually put out before any of this happened.
Blav, the guy who doxes most of the people on Kiwi Farms. Um,
the guy who Destiny is directly referenced on his stream, right?
That guy was doxing people around Destiny way before Queen and
I were a part of the picture in any major way, right? Way before
I was literally on Destiny's side while Blav was doxing people.
I told Arerodite unironically, "Hey,
this Blav guy seems to be going after people." So, no, Ardite,
I don't want to come I don't want to come on anything else. I
don't want to put myself on Destiny's team. I don't want to face
myself next to Destiny right now. Seems like this guy's kind
of got a vendetta and I don't want to be a part of that right
now. I have DMs of me saying this to Arerodite.
Hey, this seems like Kiwi Farm's kind of going unhinged on you
guys right now. I don't really want to be a part of that. No,
thank you. I don't want to come on anything else. No thanks.
Good luck. Made videos on communist
and then she'll and then she'll lean into that thing. She'll
lean in and go, I was also swatted because of these guys. Misogynist
feminists, scammers, and traffickers. people with millions of
followers. Yet, this tiny little community is where all this
doxing takes place and it's just out of their hands. Dude, they're
obviously feeding into it. But Auggie knows nothing. He can't
even recite me goofing on them accurately. Jaw has criticized
Destiny for creating a metaphorical machine partially. By the
way, by this by the these rules, I think like all of L tube is
a doxing community, right? Like every law tuber is followed religiously
on Kiwi Farms. They all criticize each other. They all do this.
Like all of Law Tube is just a huge doxing community. All of
the um well I think they probably would make this argument for
like Kino Casino, but all of those guys would be doxing communities
too because apparently if if you're a creator who does like who
does like comedy content making fun of people, criticizing people,
apparently you're responsible for anything that happens to those
people.
That's the argument these these guys are making goofing on them
accurately. Jawalk has criticized Destiny for creating a metaphorical
rap machine partially because he had with BPD girls. Then when
these girls call him out for being abusive, everyone thinks they're
just crazy. JTalk then >> Well, also also he sicks his
community on them and harasses them. There's a whole pattern
of behavior here.
>> The same BPD girl. >> Everything Destiny is saying
here is
>> Actually, it's not true. Actually,
>> sorry. I Cherry and I did get together. Yes, that is
true. >> Everything Destiny is saying here is >> But
obviously, I've never thought this. I've never said this ever
in my entire life. I've never said I I wouldn't even say if it
was just him like hooking up with a couple BBD girls back like
in a row. I don't even know that you'd criticize that, right?
It's him talking about it being something he's into and then
him like repeatedly harassing these people and like totally transparently
with these people. Okay. Anyway, so everything Destiny is saying
here is everything Destiny is saying here is true. It was just
a total lie and Willie just replplatforms that uncritically.
>> Actually, it's not true. Actually, everything Destiny
is saying here is complete Jesse says, "And to think that this
was the same guy Jason JuPug
>> is going to have Auggie's going to have a different
rationale." Augie says it's just about sharing nudes and sharing
videos. I don't think it's just about that. I think it's the
pattern of behavior, right? There's a clip of I know there is
egregious filin. I know. I know. I know. Maybe Willy's going
to play the clip you deny existing. I've already watched this.
He doesn't. He plays the infinite machine clip. >> You're
saying having mentally ill people equals crazy, huh? No. you.
That was never the argument that you have mentally ill people.
That means you're raping them by default. The argument is that
you don't give a about their consent because you'll share their
images, videos of them doing all kinds of stuff. You'll share
that with anyone. >> No, Auggie. JTO actually specifically
said it's not about sharing images. >> I think that >> it's
not. It's about the pattern of behavior. I laid this out multiple
times, right? And Auggie lays it out as well. Ryan Beard lays
it out. Why? Why does Willie understand Ryan Beard's
video? Why does he understand that somebody's describing this
pattern of behavior repeating over time? And that is the criticism,
right? It's not one of these in a vacuum. People could defend
these situations, right? In a vacuum, if you don't know anything,
you could defend individual situations. When they keep happening
over and over and over and over again, then it becomes something
else. the main talking point is that Destiny distributes people's
nudes and like it's like a weird se >> I think that's not
the same the the main talking point I think one of the big I
mean a massive talking point here is the infinite machine okay
how does the infinite machine work a massive talking point which
you'd know if you were part of the if you watch the Sunday video
this it's not just about nudes
so the infinite rake machine is a hypothetical about why Destiny
can keep doing these things, why he can wrong all of these different
people and keep getting away with it, never be held responsible,
right? That is what the infinite machine is. How like, and it
literally is about like Destiny created this orbit of people
who will defend him because they're financially incentivized
to defend him, right? That is a huge part of why Destiny keeps
getting away with this really shady conduct because people will
defend him basically no matter what. That's that's like a huge
part of the Sunday hypothetical. That's what the infinite rate
machine is about this, bro. It's about a system that let this
happen for so long. So hold on. I'll let it I'll let it go back.
A system that let this happen for so long. So how could you how
could you create a system that let this happen for so long, but
having with any mentally ill girl is rape apparently? How could
that pos how could you connect these criticisms? >> I think
that's not the same the the main talking point. I think one of
the big I mean a massive talking point here is the infinite rate
machine. Okay. How does the infinite rate machine work? This
is a massive talking point. What you'd know if you were part
of the if you watch the Sunday video is it's not just about nudes,
bro. It's about a system that let this happen for so long. >> And
what does Sunday say? Part of the machine is destiny targeting
mentally ill women. And the >> Yeah, part of the machine
is that
a persistent targeting of mentally ill women over time. Dude,
>> victims are also selected either for mental illness,
allowing them to be easily construed as hysterical or deceptive
when they complain about their treatment. So when it leaks >> Wait,
he gave an either. Where's the
Hold on. Now we have to go find What did he cut there? Cuz all
of his cuts so far have been insanely disingenuous. He is a lying
freak. So let's go see what else he cut. I must have cut something
else there, right? Let me Let me take a look. What else did he
cut here? Is the Destiny video still up here? Wait, did Sunday
take the Destiny video down? Let me look. 6 months ago. Oh, no.
No, no. It's got to be here somewhere. What? I don't see the
Destiny video here. Did he put it on President Sunday, too? Maybe
put it on President Sunday, too. Give me a second. Then we got
a link to the Destiny video. Where's Where's Sunday's Destiny
video? I don't see it here. Maybe I'm just blind. I'm looking
it up on another tab, so you guys aren't seeing it. I don't see
it up here. Oh, here it is. >> Public knowledge and most
>> Oh, let's let's just see what he cut. Oh, either for
mental illness, >> intimate and potentially life- ruining
abuse handpicked into by engaging it will create more. I urge
everyone to pay them accountable for what is clearly Let's Let's
just Let's just take it. Let's just check the whole thing out.
Hold on. Let me go.
I'm I'm going to hit play from here. Let's listen to what Sunday
says. >> Reckless abandon. Even occasionally threatening
their release if the people in them do something to displease
him. And when finally the obvious result of recklessly sharing
these intimate images with strangers occurs and they are publicly
exposed for all to see to the detriment of these people's reputations,
mental health, and safety, he is able to buy off his victims
and use their purchased silence as moral ammunition to shut down
anyone who would try to hold him accountable for what is clearly
grossly unethical conduct.
Destiny and the web he has created around himself is creating
victims. And if it is allowed to continue, it will create more.
I urge everyone to pay attention and to warn people about the
danger they are putting themselves into by engaging with Destiny
and his community. These are people who have been handpicked
for their willingness to not just remain passive in the wake
of intimate and potentially life- ruining abuse, but to also
become accompllices in silencing the victims. And the victims
are also selected either for mental illness, allowing them to
be easily construed as hysterical or deceptive when they complain
about their treatment, or for financial vulnerability, allowing
them to be easily paid off by Destiny for their silence. Thanks
to certain individ
Okay, so like there's a whole thing. He describes a whole system
and Willy's going, "Yeah, but like one part of this machine is
apparently mental illness." And like and so that means you think
it's rape one I didn't name the infinite rape machine. That is
literally that's literally Sunday's thing. That is literally
his thing. But anyway, apparently me referencing this and the
other thing is Willie Willie knows that the clip is not what
he thinks it is. Apparently me referencing this is saying all
any relationship with a mentally ill person is
>> that JTO is having a secret relationship with the same
BPD girl and she crashes out on him multiple times. It's funny
I'm giving him I'm allowed to >> uh I think basically Sherry
has had complaints about me that she posted. I think you can
just believe her, okay, when she posts those complaints. Like
just believe her. Um
yeah, she's she's valid. Jerry doesn't lie, right? Cherry. Cherry
doesn't lie. People think Cherry lies. She doesn't lie. She doesn't
lie. She might say things that make people upset. She doesn't
lie. >> Talk back to these people. I talked to Auggie about
the same exact thing a month ago and told him if he wanted to
find it, you could just watch the ending to my second Destiny
video. But he didn't watch it. He'd rather make stuff up. Bro,
you're sitting at a computer right now. Feel free to use it.
Auggie ends this. >> Wait, what is the Wait, what? Hold
on. What is the point of that? >> [__] I'm
allowed to talk back to these people. I talked. >> Yeah,
nobody has a problem with you talking Willy Mac. Nobody has any
issue with you talking [__] >> Augie about
this a month ago and told him if he wanted to find it, you could
just watch the ending to my second Destiny video. But he didn't
watch it. He'd rather make stuff up. Bro, you're sitting at a
computer right now. Feel free to use it. Auggie ends this hourong
segment on me summarizing that the only reason I'd be mad is
because I'm stupid or because Destiny controls me, feeding into
the narrative that got me doxed in the first place. It's hard
to like logically understand why he's
posting this. I mean, the two options is literally just he's
like brain dead right now or he's controlled opposition. >> That's
all you could think of? Well, let me give you a third option.
Our wedding is having to prepare for fake bomb threats and my
bride is worried about us and our family getting >> Okay,
but that you could just say, "Hey guys, I got emotional. My bad."
Right? That's literally all you got to do. You just have to say,
"Hey, I'm I'm emotional. My bad. Literally, everybody would go,
"Oh, yeah, it's understand." That's what I said. By the way,
I came out defending this to my audience. I'm like, "Yeah, I
think he's just like kind of having a moment because like I'm
I'm but like he's just having a moment cuz obviously this is
like an incredibly important day and they're now having they're
going to have to deal with this, right? I defended this shot.
Auggie never once brings this up as a possibility for why I'm
frustrated. It doesn't cross his mind. Seriously, if that
but that has nothing to do with us. You're making allegations
that are outside of you just being in your feelings, dude. You're
making actual allegations. You're saying, "I am trying to dox
you." If you if you just said, "Oh, my bad. I I accused this
guy of trying to dox me and that was kind of silly. I was emotional."
I would literally reply to that and go, "Understandable. It's
incredibly that your wedding day got with I would.
I would." That's the extent of your analysis. You need to quit.
In my last conversation with Auggie, he told me a story about
how he quit drama for a year because a guy named Salvo was doxing
and harassing him and his family. So, where is that same sympathy
when it's happening to me and my wife? He shares the same empathy
meter with Ian. >> You know, my empath what the clips he
put of Yeah, they're not. No, the clips he used of everybody
here are super disingenuous. Porter Beller, I'm just not quite
as familiar with the with the Auggie segment. I watched it, but
I I'm not quite as familiar with like the overall I don't know.
I guess I I I swear I watched it, but I watched it like right
before I went to sleep, unfortunately. It was a good segment.
It was funny segment. I might have rewatched part of it on stream,
too. I think I definitely watched clips from it. Um,
yeah. I just I think Willie is like, do you think this might
be what's happening here? Here's what I hypothesize is happening.
I think Willy's in a Discord or a Discord group chat, okay? And
people are clipping things to make other people look as bad as
possible. and he is not looking into those things in full. When
when he gets that Auggie segment, he doesn't see the whole Auggie
segment. He sees the clip that somebody shares with him and he
puts that in his video without checking anything else. That is
the only, by the way, which is totally unforgivable. It's totally
like it's a totally practice for any YouTuber, right? But that's
the only thing that explains any of this right now. Empathy meter's
only maybe like a quarter of the way filled up. The most reassuring
news I got was when my wedding planner told me that she talked
to the venue and they told her that the riff raff doesn't bother
them because they've done celebrity weddings and that they're
in a neighborhood so they're used to getting calls like this.
In one sense, very reassuring because it means our venue wasn't
spooked and in another sense very depressing because it means
people are just calling and harassing this place because they're
in a neighborhood. I don't know what should happen when it comes
to >> uh Yeah, that sucks. >> Destiny or a snark
community doxing each other? Nobody around me has ever doxed
somebody who's like close to Destiny. I'm being maliciously attributed
with that uh for no for only only out of spite. There is no factual
basis to that whatsoever. And Destiny, sorry, Willy's only factual
basis for this. His entire factual basis for every video he makes
now is just did Destiny say it? If yes, then true. That is like
what Willie does. Uh if Destiny said it, it's true. And you have
to disprove it now. Oh, he's claiming something with no evidence.
Well, I'm sure I sure you have evidence that you didn't do this.
That seems like really important that you have evidence that
you didn't do this. You got to prove a negative to me right now.
Okay. I Cool. Cool. Cool. >> But what I do know is bad
empanada needs to be banned. He non-stop slanders people, doxes
people, and harasses them. >> Oh, now we have a problem
with slander.
Apparently slander's bad now. Uh, all right. Hey, Willie, did
you think this was true when you said it? Yeah. Why? Um
>> swatted kraut by falsely reporting them to the Austrian
police for hacking his alt Twitter accounts. I don't think they
were ever hacked at all. >> He accuses me of hacking. Bad
panada accuses me of hacking. Specifically, he accuses me of
hacking 15 of his ban. >> I don't know what the actual
factual matter is here. I don't know. I don't know. Maybe
>> crowd hacking him comes from a tweet where Crouch says
he's archiving his accounts. That's literally it. This here is
the central claim. He claims I got illegal access to 15 of his
22 temporarily banned ex accounts. Well, what did I tweet? I
tweet, "Yeah, we managed to get archive files containing everything
bad and panada tweeted with 15 of his 22 suspended accounts."
Well, how did we get this? We went to way back machine and typed
in his accounts. Soing obviously is
not you hacking him. He's saying that that tweet is evidence
that he was hacked.
>> Wasn't a swatting, by the way. Just filed a police report.
Okay. Yeah. A swatting is maliciously reporting like a threat
that needs to be diffused via violence, right? Like somebody
has a gun on people, there's a bomb somewhere. It's not I don't
even think bombs. It's like explicitly there's a hostage
right? Like you want them to enter a place with their guns drawn.
That is the purpose of swatting. Saying, "Hey, this guy like
illegally docked me." that is reporting what you believe to be
a a crime. You're like a
right. If you're if if he called him and was like, I think this
guy I think this guy hacked me, then he's just dumb. He's not
he's not trying to get you like swatted. >> Actually just
uploaded a video on why he thinks his police report was justified.
And in it, he just reads his complaint. >> So this is probably
the most serious thing that he did in that he publicly >> Yeah.
If he if he filed a police report, that's not swatting. If
swatting is Hold on.
I Let's just go to Urban Dictionary. Let's see. Let's see what
this is. Swatting. A goal achieved by hacking where the hacker
tricks 911 systems into deploying SWAT to an That's stupid. No.
Uh swatting is an internet prank/crime where someone finds your
address either through the your IP or because of your name or
your name and location are known. Then they call 911 anonymously
and report a fake emergency. Example, someone can call and say
that someone at that address is being held at gunpoint or someone
is going to commit and a SWAT team would be dispatched to that
address. It is implying a SWAT team needs to be dispatched. If
you're not reporting something that a SWAT team would be dispatched
for, you're not swatting somebody. Like, how is that confusing?
Apparently for Willie, that is a very confusing concept. That
is a concept he can barely grapple with.
Wow. By the way, bada sucks. I would just prefer people don't
accuse him of fake things so he can't continue to suck because
nobody believes you. implied that he had hacked my um social
media accounts and obtained private information about me that
is otherwise inaccessible from doing so and that he was going
to go through it and share it. >> Hey, no neck. He's talking
about the public tweets you posted. Oh yeah, this tweet where
Crouch says he's going to screenshot the unhinged stuff I say.
Yeah, that's evidence he's going to hack me. Please believe me,
audience. Like how stupid are his viewers? an archive file containing
every by the way by the way I'll just point out
more evidence than Willie provided for queen somebody in queen's
community hacking him or sw or doxing him okay more evidence
than that he is calling bad empanada but bad empanada has presented
more evidence for himself being hacked that this guy had access
to his suspended accounts or the the tweets on there right there's
there's like some predicate there other than this guy said so
well this guy said so actually >> think bad empire tweeted
with 15 of his 22 suspended accounts. Now, you can't really get
an archive file of someone else's Twitter. The only way you can
get the Twitter archive file is by having access to the account.
So, that's very suspicious, isn't it? >> Or you could just
go to your public Twitter page and screenshot all your tweets.
He's so desperate to sound like a victim here when he's the one
who
pot me kettle. Pot me kettle. Pot me kettle. Just with regards
to the Twitter stuff and people making fun of him, uh, obviously
he is the victim in the doxing >> Slotted crowd. >> He
didn't want me to think that he engaged in potentially criminal
activity. Why did he make public posts implying that he was engaging
in that in that activity? Public posts that clearly the Vienna
police who investigated the case thought were suspicious enough
to warrant an investigation and an >> What bad empanad
is not telling you is that the police dismissed his complaint
as having zero merit. He's essentially reading his own complaint
and then acting like that somehow makes it more legit. It doesn't.
>> Yeah, it sounds like that complaint would not happen.
>> This is only a small portion of how stupid this police
report is. In short, the police closed the investigation because
it was a massive waste of time. But this still allowed Bad Panata
to get all of Crowd's personal information. When the police closed
the investigation, Badam Panata wrote an email threatening Crowd
to stay silent on it. prefer to not have to talk about this publicly
as you will note that I've refrained from doing up until uh that
I have refrained from doing so up until this point because I
legitimately never did any of the things you claimed I did to
you and have no wish to embarrass you or divulge any personal
info by releasing any of the files I received from the prosecutor's
office in this case. I have no issue with you as a person. I
just think your videos suck. I will not apologize for taking
basic measures to protect protect myself like filing police report
when you publicly made such statements.
I mean, there's a way you could in
if you had a lot of charity for bad empanada, there's a way you
could read. I don't particularly
um you could read this like as an honest thing. I think it probably
is more like I'll I'll just release all of this if you talk about
it. I I can see both readings. I I can see the the the oh, I'll
just release this if you talk about it one way more. >> Hi,
Joseph. I did not swort you. You gave me legitimate reason to
believe that you were hacking my accounts in an attempt to divulge
my private information and posted very public threats against
me. I'm relieved to hear that you apparently denied that you
were really engaging in this behavior. I will not apologize for
taking basic measures to protect myself, like filing a police
report when you publicly made such statements. I would prefer
to not have to talk about this publicly as you will note that
I have refrained from doing up until this point because I legitimately
never did any of the things you claimed I did to you and have
no wish to embarrass or divulge any personal info by releasing
any of the files I received from the public prosecutor's office
on this case. Or in other words, stay silent or I'm going to
post all of your personal information I got from the police.
Crowd has vented a bit about this, so bad empanadas already started
lying about the facts. Crowd is currently going around claiming
that I swatted him. In reality, I reported him to the Vienna
police because he was openly posting on Twitter about he was
stalking/doxing me for months. The prosecutor thought the evidence
I provided was suspicious enough to warrant an investigation,
especially one about him illegally accessing my data. Crowd told
me that the Austrian police are obligated to investigate every
report. And the investigation came back saying, "Man Panata had
little more than circumstantial evidence that his accusations
of violent threats can both in objective and subjective manner
not be proven due to there not being any violent threats. That
the accusation of liel or slander is not detectable. This video
is so embarrassing by him. He is non-stop lying. And from what
I've seen, Bad Empanada has no evidence. He's just wasting everybody's
time to get a dock. Seriously, dude. There's just after the previous
segment, there's just no way. Like this is an elaborate troll.
Have we gone back to Willie Max actually? Like a regular IQ elaborate
troll.
Like just elaborately trolling. Like all of his videos are just
totally disingenuous. He's just elaborately trolling right now.
There's no way he could complain about the lack of evidence that
Bad Empanada has. And then just replatform Destiny's accusations
with no proof whatsoever. How is this guy not banned from everything?
There is some good news though. Bad empanada is apparently on
the run. I thought it was just a meme when he posted today's
stream is delayed as I am fleeing to a different country. But
it turns out this might be real as Ethan is monologuing his next
move to track him down. Bad Empanada is on the run. He knows
we're closing in. We suspected he had fled back to Australia,
but upon further research and verification, he's actually fled
to Uruguay. This information is probably shocking for him to
hear as he went to great lengths to obscure his escape from Argentina
to Uruguay. Bad empanada, if you ever decide to return to Australia,
will be immediately notified and a torrent of lawsuits will follow.
You are easy to get in Australia, which is why you're doing everything
to avoid returning. Why am I telling you this? So he looks over
his shoulder every day. >> This guy thinks he's so cool.
I What? If you actually wanted to get this guy, you would just
not say anything, right? You just want to look cool. You just
want people to go, "You're so awesome, Ethan. Ethan, you're so
awesome. Oh my god, look at your thoughts. It's so cool." We
don't we don't care. It's like weird and gay, but
just just try to go after him. Just try to like Don't tell them,
"Oh, if you go here, I'll get you." Just get him. We are coming
and we will win. You can run from us, but we will catch you and
we will ruin you.
How is that better than what bad empanada does? Um, it's not.
But they're going to argue that you can do that because
they're going to argue you can do that cuz he docks his people,
right? I'm not like I'm not going to defend. Bad empanada knows
the world he put himself in. I don't have to defend him. He knows
how to defend himself. >> Have a nice day. >> Bad
empanada chimed in. Does it feel good to be hated literally everywhere
you go? I mean, first of all, Benanata, you you're outcast from
society. Like, we live in Los Angeles, California. You are on
the run.
>> I mean, you know, you're a piece of [__]
when even his son pulls up bad and panata's video of him doxing
me and even he's surprised about what's happening. >> Just
like how I can tell you that Willie Mac Show is William McConville
and um he is getting married to a Yale. Now, I am not going to
give you the full name of um the person he's getting married
to, but I can tell you she is. This is by by the way, I just
I feel like I'm totally justified. I was like, I'm not going
to watch a bad empanada video cuz I never know when he's going
to like frame skip into some doc [__] Like, I will
never watch one of his videos cuz out of nowhere there'll be
some doc in there. No thank you. Not going to click on it on
stream. Not going to watch that on stream. I don't want to do
it. >> Israeli and she was assigned to him by
>> That's not even her. It doesn't matter. Bad empanada
is still attempting to do something. Even if that weren't the
right name that would be totally The kid pictures not being heard
is just embarrassing for bad empanada, right? But it's still
the intent. The intent is >> Skip. To be honest, >> the
intent is >> this is drama slob and banana content. Yeah,
I don't really give a [__] about >> Like I
appreciate that he stopped watching immediately, but why are
we acting like it's just slop? I'd argue it's a bit more ill
than slop content. Assan is a guy who thinks the subreddit LSF
posting his stream clips quantifies as stalking and harassment.
>> If I was a smart person, I wouldn't be getting ritualistically
humiliated by socially maladjusted
freaks that are agorophobic on a daily basis in a mass harassment
campaign on >> Hey, I'm not agorophobic online, but I do
that for a living. >> But Bad Empanada posting my personal
info, eh, it's just drama slop. Then he watches him again a few
days later. Empanada is a good good example of this where I think
he's like a crazy person. Uh he is a chaotic good if that makes
>> No, it doesn't. Please explain. >> Like think
about how little I I uh think about how little I little time
I spend like on bad empanada or whatever. Cuz like I think he's
coming from like we have different methods. We have different
uh tactics. We have different >> His tactics are doxing,
false police reports, false CPS reports, slandering people constantly.
But uh overall uh we're working on the same side. >> Hassan
is literally saying he supports what bad empanada is doing. Like
Assan clearly knows at this point who bad empanada really is.
He literally had a one-on-one conversation with him where bad
empanada said these people deserve to be harassed. Meaning anyone
who mildly disagrees with them. >> What do you mean? Bad
empanada did not do CPS. He literally just does that to with
people. Okay. He just does it to with people. He literally he
literally just leans into it, right?
That's all it is. That's all it is. >> Slandering people
constantly. >> But uh overall
we're working on the same >> Hassan is literally saying
he supports what bad empanada is doing. Like Hassan >> I
mean he probably supports like I would say in Hassan's heart
of hearts I think he probably supports people getting more escalatory
in terms of fighting against pro-Israel propaganda. I don't think
he thinks about how that applies. I don't think he thinks but
like he's not saying it on stream. He's not openly saying I support
doxing on stream. He's saying I support like the Palestinian
movement. I support anti-Israel content.
That's what that's what he does. I know that sucks. Okay. And
Hassan should be more careful. Hassan I would expect Hassan to
come out and go, "Oh, I put that on stream. That's my bad. I
removed it. I got all my editors to remove it. My bad." Right.
But unfortunately for Hassan, I kind of understand this at this
point. I will always do it because I am a I am like a Canadian
a polite Canadian optics on some things, okay, around certain
topics. So, I will always say, "Oh, I feel empathy for Willy
Mack here." I'll always say, "Oh, I [__] this up.
I should correct it." Right? I'll always do that. But I understand
that Hassan's gotten nothing out of that. Right? When Hassan
corrects things, when Hassan goes, "Guys, anybody suggesting
Ethan doesn't take care of his kids is in the head. You for saying
that, like, don't say that. Go outside. Get a life." Okay. Hassan
said that on his stream, but every time Hassan gets brought up,
the CPS thing still gets webbed to him. It doesn't matter that
he disavowed it. Every time I I I was super I majorly disavowed
the [__] that happened to Willie Mack. I banned people.
I deleted comments. Right. And what was what was my reward for
that? Being lied about maliciously in his video for 15 minutes.
Like it doesn't it doesn't matter. I'll do it for myself because
it's what's right to do. It's what is right. But it's it it starts
to get a little like annoying or a little black pilling when
you can have the right opinion. You can actually say what's true
and then everybody will still lie about you anyway. So I I feel
a little empathy for Son there. Okay. >> Clearly knows
at this point who bad empanada really is. He literally had a
one-on-one conversation with him where bad empanadas said these
people deserve to be harassed. Meaning anyone who mildly disagrees
with them. >> Be mean to them. If they feel if they feel
bad, if they feel harassed
great. I don't give a
them each and every one of them. We need to be mean to these
guys. We need to be they deserve >> He knows the guy he's
supporting is doing this and purposely promotes them anyway.
A week passes and they're pinging out about my docs and pedalling
lies about my wife to discredit valid criticism about them. They're
just trying to my character. >> You're just doing uh investigative
journalism. They're saying bada unearthed that. Is that true?
I think bad or one of somebody somebody unearthed like the the
Willie Mack shows getting married to like a IDF lady or >> just
openly lying.
>> Yeah, it's really up when somebody takes someone who's
known to maliciously lie about people, maliciously docks people
and just replplatforms their allegations with no proof behind
it whatsoever. Doesn't it Willie? It actually really sucks when
that happens to you, doesn't it? I I feel like we could all come
together and agree, Willie, that when someone takes the allegations
and the blatant lies of a known malicious liar and puts him in
a big YouTube video or on a big stream, that kind of sucks when
it's about you. I think we can all say that's bad, right? Right.
Which makes sense. He was the guy who did the the big expose
on on like you with the Ali bombing, hospital bombing, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. He's a a brilliant political
probably one of the best minds in politics right now. >> Truth.
So yeah, compromise. >> Like man, I just keep forgetting
you could justify anything as long as you're more pro Palestine
than the other guy. I want to end this video with a story. When
I was at my most overwhelmed figuring out all the new logistics
for the wedding, Ethan Klein actually hit me up and offered to
organize security for it so everyone could have peace of mind
and enjoy the day. He had no reason to do that. I don't know.
I made videos. I mean, he definitely wanted to shout out for
it, but I don't think you would have asked for it. I don't think
he would have brought it up. So, yeah, I I think that's like
a W to say, "Hey, I I see you're getting harassed. You're like
nice to me. I'm going to help you out." That's a nice thing.
>> Got him in the past, but he reached out anyway and lent
a hand when he had no reason to. What got me was a text you he
totally had a reason to. He totally empathizes with you being
harassed by bad empanada. He totally had a reason to, right?
sent me saying >> like you you have you have solidarity.
>> I got you, bro. Don't worry, your wedding will be perfect.
It was. So, thank you. Subscribe to the channel and buy a wallet.
Shout out to the homies over on Patreon. Crimson Glass. >> All right.
Um
yeah, just uh I don't really care about the bad section all that
much to be honest. I think um yeah, I I feel like Hassan probably
is cozying up a little bit too much, right?
But I I just see the funny thing is is I try to be accurate.
I don't just I don't just repost or replatform any of these things,
right? I don't do that. I put myself firmly outside of the circle.
Queen has put himself firmly outside of this circle. I get no
I get no
respect and no care for that. Oh, this is true. This is a big
difference. Yeah. Ethan offered to pay for Willie security. And
when Destiny was asked like, "Hey, are you going to warn um Hutch
or Josiah about their docs?" Yeah. No. He's like, "No, they can
figure it out on their own." No, they can figure it out on their
own. True. Ethan is at his heart, at his core, an actual human
being. He's kind of get going to a place, but he's an actual
human being. Destiny is a lizard.
Destiny is inhuman.
Yes.
Thank you for pointing that out. All right. What are we doing
here? What are we doing here? What are we doing here? I've got
the I've got the the Fuentes thing as well, but I was going to
see if people are going to come on. See what's uh what's Malo
doing? Moral live. Is Moral live? I'm in my Discord channel now.
Ralph's not live anymore. Aiden is live. Okay, we'll see if people
want to hop on at some point tonight. >> Christina, Dancock,
Necro Valley, The Confusing Opinion, Eddie Bizzle, Tismic Fitz,
Christopher H, Senial Music, Lucasit, ET Automatic, Snoopy Poop.
>> Oh, I don't want to watch this anymore. Oh, hey. What's
up, Mal? How's it going? >> Dude, it is like I don't know.
I I I don't know if I'm like naive and this has just happened
all the time and I'm only realizing it now that I'm like paying
attention.
But this is crazy. Like every single clip, maybe being a little
hyperbolic, but like most of the clips in the video are either
cut short, cut context, disingenuous, or just like outright lies.
Like the clip when he talks about Quan, he's like Quimman's saying
this is justified against me. He's talking about
>> What the hon is literally saying under Destiny's worldview,
which is insane and I don't share. This is what is allowed. Yes,
obviously. He's he's he's obviously making a reference to Destiny
because in the month of July alone he like
did a whole like an insane amount of doxing stuff. Like it's
like obviously he's referencing Destiny and then he's like um
I don't know what should happen to Destiny but bad empanada should
be banned. And it's like these people do the same thing. You
should be consistent. Yeah. If you want bad empanada banned,
Destiny should be banned too. There's no way that when when uh
Noah just when Noah restates
information from a known liar who docks his people who is like
a horrible reputation, right? And Willie goes, "He said this
without evidence. It's so disgusting that they do this when his
entire like 15-minute section here is just him doing the exact
same thing Noah was doing, right? It's just him repeating Destiny's
garbage instead of Noah repeating Bad and Panata's garbage. And
he just doesn't connect it whatsoever. You literally can't connect
it at all. >> Yeah. I I Dude, it's like I I I had like
the first part of my script written for uh for the Willie Mac
thing. I have to like go through and rewrite everything because
I was just going to call him like like Yeah, he was probably
emotional, but like this is not how you should respond to like
your doc's getting out. But at this point, he's just like completely
and utterly malicious. He's like using his wife. I saw Aiden
tweet this and I like agree. He's literally using his wife as
like a human shield. He's like, "Dude, my wife was scared she
was going to get shot in the head. My wife is like like, "Bro,
what? You you did this. You confirmed the docs 3 days before
your wedding, right? It sucks that you got bomb threats or whatever,
if that's even true." But like, you confirmed this. You you allowed
this avenue of attack. You went on your Twitter, said, "This
is real. This is where my wife and I are going to be in 3 days."
Like, it it's it's so insane how he can just >> Cherry
asked him to take down that audio, right? Cherry asked him to
take down that audio, and his response was, "I don't think this
really hurts you in any way." Uh, so no, I should go to YouTube
legal. >> Yeah. No, he's he's he's
crazy. I I don't I don't get it. I I I genuinely don't get it.
I don't understand it. And then he's like he's going after um
I'm like he's so inconsistent in the video. He's like, "I don't
care that like uh or Destiny was I don't care that Destiny was
defending me. My docs is already viral." And then he's complaining
that like um he's like, "Well, Auggie showed my docs uncensored."
And it's like, "Bro, do you care? Do you not care?" Like his
arguments change every five seconds. >> Did Auggie show
his docs uncensored?
>> Yeah, that was one of his arguments. >> Oh, no,
no, no. He showed he showed links to my docs uncensored.
>> Uh, I believe his as well when he was covering uh Sure.
I mean, yeah, yours as >> I thought No, no, no. I thought
he actually argued he was actually upset that they didn't play
the Queen and clip, right? I thought that was what it was. They
were He was upset that they didn't play the Queen clip or sorry,
Audi didn't play the Queen. I >> I could be mixing things
up. There was a lot in the video. Um, >> yeah, I'll show
the digger suite. But, uh, one of Willy's criticisms is also,
so if it's he didn't show my doc or he showed my docs. >> What
do you guys think of Loner Box's take on doxing? Uh, is this
actually real? I'll pull it up. He He's mad that Auggie didn't
watch the clip with Queen in it, right? He is He's actually mad
about that yellow. Well, I guess >> here, hold on. >> And
the the light shines back. >> Dan Saltman know the identity
of that yellow cat grifter? Well, I guess everyone does now because
it's published. Yeah. And I just I'm sorry. I can't have any
sympathy for someone who does it to other people. Like why would
you? I think if you dox people, you you deserve to get dog. So
I'm gez.
Uh so then it starts to become okay. Then is this not just the
um it's so up in a world where they're also just lying about
what other people do or what they're involved in? Like I'd say
you have to like actually maliciously dox people yourself. That
has to be the standard, right? You have to say I'm publishing
this information because I hate this person or something. or
even for any reason. You're just publishing the information yourself
because I I
that sounds like that could be a position I don't care about
or would be but I you'd have to know, right? They'd have to do
it themselves. It can't just be based on innuendo. That can't
be it. Can't be the line. >> If a doctor gets doxed or
something like that, it's like I I will never feel bad for that.
>> Like I wouldn't feel bad for bad and Panic plays by
those rules. I wouldn't feel bad for Destiny plays by those rules,
right? anybody plays by those. But it's it sucks when you're
somebody who doesn't and explicitly says they don't and explicitly
like disavows it and then people like you play by those rules,
huh? Nobody cares if you get doxed, right? That's it's [__]
>> in that case. That's I don't know. It's [__]
crazy.
>> I can't believe he he straight up just says, "Well,
Queman's community doxes people with no evidence." Lays out zero
evidence for that point. His his evidence for like wants me doxed
is Queman laughed when he said when he disavowed the comment.
I don't know if you want to pull it up. I did DM you while you
were at that section, but like yeah, his his whole thing with
like Queenman's community docs, me is just a total lie. If you
look into it for like five seconds, it's just totally false.
Like he just lies. I don't even know if he looked into it. I
don't even know if I can call it like a malicious lie. It could
just be a mistake. I don't know. But like it's just wrong. It's
just wrong. You can look at where he said I don't know if I'm
allowed to say the word on the stream, so I'll be vague. But
you can look at where he says the docs originated. Look who posted
>> Kiwi Farms. I don't care if you say Kiwi Farms on here.
I mean, it seems like
>> it's just like the guy who posted
no mention of so nothing. >> Two posts, two posts on his
account. None of them mention Queman. It It's ridiculous. It's
like >> I think it just has to be Malice at this point.
I mean, Malice is clouding his judgment, but his judgment is
so compromised. Like Malice can cloud anybody's judgment, right?
But most people are like out of self-preservation are like, "Yeah,
I hate this person, but I'm not going to go shoot them in the
head in the head. Not because I want them to be happy or healthy,
but because I don't want to go to jail, right? Or not even necessarily
because of my own morality. Uh I would say for me, my morality,
I don't want to kill people. But I'm just saying hypothetically,
you could do it out of self-preservation, too. Most people, even
if they don't have a moral like qual with something, if it's
like really bad, they won't do it. But that's just not kicking
in for Willie. He's just like lying. And he's like, I feel like
this should risk his channel, right? Like in terms of his his
viewership. Like he is just transparently lying. There should
just be easy videos that go up about this and show how he's transparently
lying. Who c I think it's crazy if Nicholas doesn't react to
this video cuz he very often does react to Willie Mack videos
and if he doesn't say like I need to see some evidence of this,
you can't just say this with no evidence, right? Because I think
the evidence is Queman called somebody, right? I think the evidence
is basically
Queman was mad at Hutch. Queenman thinks Hutch is a real and
then Hutch's docs were posted in that thread or was posted in
that thread and that is a progression that happened through time.
You cannot blame that on Queman one because the docs was already
posted in the thread before that. Hutch's docs was posted in
the thread before Queman ever talked about him. Okay, before
Que ever had his little thing with Hutch, Hutch's docs was in
that thread. So one, it's not even the original like it wasn't
the original source of the docs where that came out.
Okay, and two, Quimman doesn't like that. He doesn't direct people
to do that. And even if Destiny's Kiwi Farms thread watches Queman
because they think he's funny, you cannot blame Quman for giving
his thoughts and then them going, "Well, I guess uh this person."
Yeah, Queen made some really good points about how much of a
that is or how much of a that guy is. I'm going to go after him.
Yeah, we disavow that. Do not do that. I guess the other >> you
and Freeman are literally the only like community adjacent to
Destiny I feel and maybe Loner Box too I I or whatever like who
openly say like don't dox this is bad this is wrong do not do
this Destiny literally encourages it like I I don't know and
how how does Willie come to these conclusions where it's like
Queen and and Joc's community are doing this it's Destiny it
is literally Destiny that's doing this everybody that is doxed
in this space you can tie it back to Destiny it's It's so dude.
And the funny thing is is I don't want to reference like specific
things. There's like a lot of evidence of this that Destiny is
malicious with this. That Destiny will direct people to Kiwi
Farms to dox them explicitly, right? There's a lot of evidence.
Anna, I literally wrote that in my script. >> Sorry. You
can you can put Anna on there. There's new evidence. There's
like new things that happened. I I But I don't want to go through
it, right? Like obviously like this guy is just totally malicious.
He's >> But I'm saying Anna because it's like years old.
I think that's safe to bring >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, she literally called him out for it, right? >> Yeah.
Yeah. So, I there there is evidence of implicitly and explicitly
and Yeah. Yeah. Sorry, Paul. Go ahead. I I didn't mean to interrupt
that. >> Oh, I was just going to say anonymous, thank you
for the gifted sub. You can go off explicitly. Implicitly. >> Yeah.
He there there is like numerous evidence of him implicitly and
explicitly uh doing doces, supporting doces,
sending people to doc information. Like I I it it this video
like I I know it's like mostly mostly or if not mostly like in
part a meme that that Willie still likes Destiny, right? But
with this video he he has to purposely ignore so much to get
to the conclusions that he does. It's like I don't think Destiny
should be banned but bad empanada. It's like bro Destiny has
done this for longer. He's done it to greater severity. Uh, Vat
Empanada, as far as I understand, correct me if I'm wrong, obviously.
Has he hasn't he only doxed creators? >> Um, I don't know.
>> Okay. Well, I don't want to speak on that then if you
don't know. Um, yeah, >> I literally don't know.
>> I don't feel any need to >> I they're the same.
I don't feel any need to like really defend or or like even classify
what bad empata does cuz it it's like literally all that does
is give people the ability to go, well, actually there's this
thing bad empatada did that's way worse, so you're wrong. It's
like, okay, I don't have to I don't have to even reference bad
empanada. Like, bad empanada. I don't I don't care. I just reference
this. >> I said this on my stream, but literally the only
difference between bad empanada and destiny is one of them is
like being accused of multiple crimes. >> It's like both
of these people are bad. One of them is like significantly worse.
I feel like I I I don't know like how can you make this video?
Destiny is the one who signal He also says like bad empanad is
the one who who signal boosted it and made it go viral. Destiny's
Twitter post had 200,000 views. Bad empanada's video to this
day only has 70,000. I don't understand how you could think that
bad is the one that made this go viral. >> Like the Gatumodor
post, you'd have to you'd have to subtract all the views from
Destiny's quote tweet, right? >> Like I don't even know
if Gatumodor's post. I don't know how wide that would have gone,
>> but um like Destiny was probably the person amplifying
it most. And Destiny's a lightning rod. Like when Destiny does
quote tweet something that is going to get push back from people.
Yeah, that is going to amplify massively like the ampl amp amplification
factor of like Destiny's tweets versus most people's like he
will get way more engagement with his tweets. Yeah, exactly mode.
Yeah, I just think I think when you go like well actually Destiny's
probably worse. It's just like Yeah, maybe. But I don't really
care. They're both Yeah. pieces of [__] Really? I
just play >> To be clear, I'm not trying to like tier list
this like Destiny is actually like the specific line in his video
where it's like one of these people should be banned and one
of them shouldn't. It's like, okay, no, like be consistent, please.
You I don't I don't you don't I you don't need to tier list.
You don't need to say like one of them's worse, one of them is
whatever. Both of them spread doces. Uh both of them do bad things.
If you want to have a position that doxing is bad and you should
be banned off of a platform if you spread doces, uh then you
should have the position that Destiny should also be banned.
Don't do this where you're still trying to appeal to DGG and
say like, "No, actually Destiny shouldn't be banned." It's like
it it's so it's so it's so stupid. like both of them or none
of them. You can't have it both ways. I don't know. >> Uh
I do like that he also was like, I don't even know how this guy
stole a platform. It's like, dude, if you if I'll forgive Willie
for everything, okay, I'll forgive him for everything he's ever
done to me. Okay, for against me, I'll forgive it all. I'll love
Willie if he gets like if he convinces somehow somebody at YouTube
to start looking at offplatform behavior and evaluating that
under the YouTube to like ban people for extreme off-platform
behavior. Let's go.
That's all I need. That's all I need. That'd be awesome
because holy [__] there are some people who need
some YouTube justice for for their actions. Okay. Apparently
Nicholas is going to watch the video tomorrow. We'll see what
he has to say. >> Oh, I saw Food Shops is watching it today.
I I went live and then like 20 minutes later they went live.
I should have stayed cuz I wanted to see what they had to say.
I watched them over the um the Brad Tay stuff. They watched Destiny's
stuff and they were saying some like really [__]
So, I want to I want to watch that tomorrow as well. The
>> Yeah, that's the new DG brain trust over there. The
the observer.
>> They were they were begging for it, dude. They were
begging for it. Brad Tate's girlfriend was begging to be hit.
Okay. She deserved it. She deserved to get mouth punched. All
right.
>> With his like meth. >> It's crazy stuff. It's
wild and crazy stuff. Uh guys, I just going to do a show real
quick. Guys, if you like the content, please consider subscribing,
donating, okay? Explanation boy. Donate in the chat. will give
you the TTS methods. We're I don't know. We're some amount of
money before for more away from more hours on the stream. I'll
do discussions. If we aren't getting much for donos, I'm probably
going to head out after I do some discussions on this and maybe
look at some some of the Twitter comments. You guys got Twitter
links, okay? If you see Twitter commentary, funny tweets about
this my way. Let me let me see it all because I've not I didn't
get a chance to go look around on Twitter before this. So, there's
funny stuff my way. All right. Anyway, um
>> what else needs to be said? It's also kind of that I
feel like it would be cool to go and do like Twitter spaces or
have a conversation around this like make it sort of more interesting.
>> Everybody's too scared to stand up against Willie. It's
like >> no at this point I would say all the people who
are willing to actually take a look at this and call it out also
have already done so like like really is Willie behaving is Willie
exhibiting any new behavior here? I feel like everything he's
done here he's already been criticized for. This is just more
egregious and embarrassing of an example. But like he's he already
was just replatforming Destiny. >> That's [__]
that's ballsy. >> I guess he he went he went at Auggie.
He's going to get he's going to get his cheeks clapped for that.
I do think it's really funny that Oh, hold on. Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait. Oh, there's no way he'll hop on. I'm
going to message Auggie. We'll see if he's going to come on.
I did want to ask him because there was um
uh Willie says that like Auggie I had a conversation with Auggie
and Auggie said the reason he quit is because he was being doxed
and if that wasn't private and he just confirmed that Auggie
was getting doxed and potentially confirmed >> it was it
was definitely public. It was definitely public that they were
like trying to find him that like Salvo was trying to find >> I
don't know if it was public that that's the reason Auggie quit.
I think most people just thought that like, oh, he just got bored,
did something else, and then came back later. >> Yeah,
but I'm saying it's like already public. They were trying to
dox him. And I think like I think the city he lived in was public
at the time, too, or something. I think >> so. I'm saying
I don't I don't think there is more there. I don't know. Maybe
>> maybe you could argue that like you're kind of giving
away that that irritated Auggie and like you're sort of giving
an attack surface and that's not appreciated,
right? Like, oh, this really really bugged him when uh somebody's
trying to dox him. Like it just seems like something to say that
like if he ever gets in a fight with somebody you're maybe giving
>> let's say let's say you get doxed and then you quit
and but you don't tell anybody. Nobody knows that you got doxed
and you quit because you got doxed like full address everything's
out there right and then like a year later you come back and
then you only tell one person and that one person's like, "Oh
yeah, he quit because he got doxed." I feel like that in like
all that information, right? When when >> Oh, you're good.
>> Oh, go ahead. >> You roboted for a second. >> You're
good. >> Oh, my bad. I I feel like it that inadvertently
confirms the the the docs, right? Whereas if if the person does
not confirm it, it's it's more or less like left up in the air,
like plausible deniability,
stuff like that, right? Does that make sense what I'm getting
>> Sure. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I don't I don't believe any
of that is a concern here necessarily, but I guess we'll see
as stuff comes out. >> Yeah. I mean, I I would want to
ask him to clarify. Um obviously, I don't I don't I'm not I'm
not friends with a guy. I don't have any contact, so I I wouldn't
know. But yeah, if he comes on, I'd like to ask him about that
cuz that's crazy. That's crazy. If he's if he's doing like I
don't know. I I >> This is like the This is such a bad
video, dude. Holy [__] >> Um Yeah, it's goofy.
I don't know. I I would take call-ins, but like nobody ever wants
to call in. Um
I don't I just don't get DJers anymore. I don't know. I It sucks,
but it's like obvious cuz like I know people call in, but we
need uh we need different topics. The DGs have been humiliated
too many times. They've lost all will to live in this server.
Very sad.
>> Very, very sad.
>> How would you describe your community? Cuz I feel like
you're and Queman's community, maybe not Queenman so much, but
like your community at least is very, very like DG and Jason,
right? >> Um, yeah, there's like overlap or there used
to be a lot of overlap. I don't know if there's as much overlap
anymore.
>> I just feel like when he when he says like Jtock has
a docin community, it's like that's not too far off from Destiny.
Like I don't know if like that you you cover a lot of Destiny,
you talk about Destiny, you're in the same like broad sphere
as him. Like these are not two separate communities of people
that never interact with each other, are never the same people.
It's like come on. I I like I don't know. I It's just like when
you say Jtock has a doc community, not so much Queman because
I think I think Queman kind of has his own thing, but like with
you specifically, it's like no, you really don't. It's like a
lot of even if people in your community doc it's like they're
more >> Destiny participate in this community for a long
time. So I don't know if he says like oh all these people joined
but then even if they join it's like they take screenshots of
my server. Is that like being a part of a
if taking screenshots of my server is going to make you like
a Kiwi farmer or something then I got bad news for Destiny with
his 20 albums of plugged from from my server. So >> Uh
there's a lot of XD cheers in the Discord. True. There are. That's
facts. And I don't know if you uh if you guys do want to call
in, you join the callins channel. If you got any points that
we haven't brought up on stream yet, you join the channel. I'm
just looking for I don't know more um more of this more tweets
around this. Let me go let me go look into this. See what's going
on. No, not that. No, not that. No, not that. See here. Oh, I
don't have music playing either. Damn. Let me pull up music here
real quick, guys. Oh, the cabal is angry with me. And I'm not
going to specify which one. Did anything else get said here?
It's both.
I'm not specifying which one. It's both. That's funny. Uh, I
don't think >> I'm gonna head off. I'll watch. If if something
epic happens, I'll be watching. Okay. If something epic
>> I'll talk to you later. >> Awesome. All right.
See you later. >> Space Ghost, thank you for the three
gifted DG had a brain drain and won't make themselves look that
dumb. Other than the sick offense, bro. Apparently, we'll see.
I don't know. I take callings from everybody. I don't know. You'd
think they'd come and and make their points, but no, I I just
like talking to people, but who disagree? See here. Confusing
opinion reposts the Nicholas retweet.
You just say it's Willie. So 3,000. Don't think it's about me.
Any thoughts or opinions on the video you retweeted? Anything
stand out? Absolutely none. Maybe when I get around to watching
it tomorrow, I will. Space goes, thanks for another gifted sub.
Let's go. That's five gifties. That's awesome. Six gifties on
the stream. Let's go. Cabal was a backup name for your company,
Lau.
It actually it was actually going to be the name of it. Lol.
Thank god I made I was made aware, man. Destiny actively discourages
DG from interacting with you. I mean, he actively brigades my
server repeatedly. What is this? Wait, what is that? Just reminder
that Doro chucked you under the bus. Oh, for Auggie. Oh, did
I not get music going?
There we go. Nick is farming the [__] out of Willie.
Interesting. Yeah, I agree with this chat. BBD. Oh, did Dan post
about it? Hold on, Willy. Oh.
Oh, I saw this from Anakasparian.
Yeah.
Our country is occupied and controlled by the Israelis. This
is our fight. They're using our money and our bombs to slaughter
innocent people and steal land. And then our media tells us the
Muslim world hates us for our freedom. And people believe this
that slop as they lose public services because their resources
are being sent abroad. The jig is up. You either love America
or you're the country or the country occupying it.
That's incredibly spicy from Anakasparian. Holy [__]
That's actually incredibly spicy. That's incredibly spicy thing
to tweet. This is why I married you. The Cabal is pretty slick.
Really enjoying controlling everything. Shh, Willie, they're
going to revoke your Discord membership. You only have temporary
provisional access until you get your Israeli passport. Wow.
Oh, Dan's Dan's uh [__] mac shows latest on getting
docked by leftists like Badam Panata and Assad. Liel. Willie
has a massage provided IDF wife. Reality. She's been in the US
since she was a baby. Her only crime is being fake photos/info.
Liel has consequences. Very interesting. Very interesting. Do
you think Dan watched the video? The real question is, how does
a redneck named Willie convince a fine queen to marry him? I
bet you own a jet ski. The world is falling apart. Dude, Dan
wants that podcast back. Dan wants that podcast.
It's crazy. And actually, people actually think this guy is funny.
Swear to God, Destiny's friends are such cringy astroturfed losers.
They posted the airike clip.
Wow. Okay. Um I was going to see if people wanted to hop on.
I don't know if I want to do the fun test thing tonight. I'll
be honest, guys. I was kind of I was kind of pushing myself towards
maybe I'll take the night off is what I was thinking. And then
this Willie video dropped and I was like, "Okay, I we should
we should we should go and look. We should go and take a look."
You think Nick going to give his opinion on on something? this
controversial on Twitter. People are wanting his opinion to to
his li Okay, cool.
I I just don't Yeah, that's fine. That's fine. I just think Nick's
got to have the obvious opinion on this one, right? I'll need
to see the evidence. Let me see the evidence of this. All right.
See what else we got going on here. All doxing is bad. So, I'm
sure you also, in the attempt to be fair and balanced, talk about
your involvement with Ethan, your appearance on his podcast,
and how you've both put the docs info of others into your collective
works. Right. Right. Wow, I sat through all of this Willy Waiting
for Fontes. We get to 15 subs, I'll do the Fontes thing tonight.
I'll do it tonight if we get to 15. Funny clip. What's the funny
clip? I can't click through this stupid UI. It's so stupid. Ah,
back to my other kick dashboard. Give me a sec. We'll check it
out. We got like 10, 15 minutes and we'll do it tomorrow night
if we have >> A doxing allegation to his community based
on nothing. It's crazy. You're prescribing a doxing allegation
to his community based on nothing. It's crazy.
>> We like that. That's a good post. Uh, so Willie has
become like Dark Viper. Matt said pretty much the same thing
about Chudlo Logic and Nicholas Yoro. >> Obviously a dog
whistle to with me with this. Bad empanada did not originate
my docs. He maliciously spread it everywhere, but my docs originated
on a niche forum. >> Chief Fenta has second followup on
Tucker. I did not. No, I did not. Post this. We already post
this. Dude, did Yakmo must have gone in on Willie, right? Take
a look. Uh yeah, apparently Kiwi Farms is Queenman's forum. It's
kind of wild. How will Nick break his back to ignore or justify
this one?
Oh, the Toastify thing. Cool. Toastify tweeted about it, too.
Wait, did they say did they blame me for posting the screen caps?
I don't post any screen caps. The [__] Farms is actually
a dog whistle for Queenman Farms or something. Damn. Uh, this
is actually false. Lumpy Willy, I don't know if Lumpy Willy's
around, but this is actually false, buddy. Uh, you're referring
unless you're not referring to Blav. Blav did not post this as
far as I know. I think that guy has not posted. I think the guy
that did the Willie thing's not a regular poster.
Unless I Unless I missed my Unless I up my intel on this one.
Hold on. Let me check real quick. Let me check. I'll check again.
I'll make sure this morale sent me some of this stuff. Yeah.
No, that was a like new account that did that. Anyone knows what
a Willy Mac is outside of the space? Nobody knows who any of
this stuff is outside of the space. All of this is incredibly
niche stuff. Full of hell. Yes. Quiqu farms. I think Quiqu Farms
is a better way to do it. Not qui
farms is a better way to do it. Okay. I don't know if we're going
to pull people on tonight and I'm kind of I'll be honest. I was
probably skipping tonight. Oh, there's a Tucker CIA thing. I'll
check it out tomorrow. Evily Bravo. I just want to come on do
the Willie thing real quick and then hop off. So, I love you
guys.
I'll I might I might take tomorrow off. I'm not totally sure.
Play civ. No, I'm uh I'm out. I'm out. Did you cover scavenger
hunt? I did not. No, I started late. I'm ending early. Start
late and early. Okay. Yeah, it was a short stream tonight. I
didn't It's why I didn't put a timer up. Okay. I love you guys.
I will be back tomorrow. We'll do Well, sorry. I will be back
tomorrow or the next day. Okay.
But I might also need a night off here, so we'll see. Okay, guys.
Have a good night. We'll talk to you later. Is Quman still online?
Queen is still online.
Go watch him. He's watching a movie or something. I don't know.
Watching movie scenes. Some [__] Good luck, guys.
Go check out Queenman. Yeah. Sorry. I was going to take the night
off and I just figured I'd go live and cover this Willy Mack
video cuz it was so stupid. Have a good night, guys.